good morning ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the science technology and
energy committee please
stand and join lex brezhney as he leads
to the allegiance for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
all was a little bit surprised when i
arrived this morning to see the message
boards down in the lobby didn't list
this meeting this morning but it is
listed in the calendar
so i'm going to
uh trust that everybody who
needed to be here for this meeting
is here
one person who is conspicuously absent
from this meeting is the subcommittee
chair representative doug
thomas when he scheduled this meeting he
forgot that he had an 8 30 medical
appointment in nashua
and he said he would be here as soon as
he could get here after that medical
appointment so we expect the arrival of
representative thomas
virtually any minute
there are a couple of other things i'd
like to discuss
committee issues
before we get into this substance of our
subcommittee meeting
and that is last tuesday we had a
organizational meeting about our interim
study bills
and we reviewed six interim study bills
and our committee researcher kristen
sitting in the back there
happened to notice that there were two
interim study bills from the previous
year that we forgot to
include in last week's organizational
meeting they were house bill 213
and senate bill
and
both of those bills will need to be
included
adjudicated by us in the fall
so i just wanted to remind all committee
members of that
and
point out that we will
make a judgment about whether to
recommend or not recommend
so with that i guess we can begin our
meeting today now as i pointed out
representative thomas is the
subcommittee chair and he had an agenda
for this meeting
unfortunately i do not know what that
agenda is or was
so i'm not sure how we're going to
proceed here this morning
i guess we could start by asking if
there are any committee members who
would like to
say anything before we
uh begin our session go ahead
representative abrami thank you i just
want to point out to the committee that
this
meeting is being live streamed
and it will be available afterwards as
well
in addition
if time permits i do have some other
folks here
it's my understanding we have several
industry folks that are going to be
speaking
and i do have some others here that
would like to to chime in if if possible
if time permits
okay thank you representative yeah go
ahead representative abrami something
else
oh yes and i think we have
um
some some of the lobbyists could could
uh chime in as to who who the speakers
are and what order they'd like to go in
if if doug doesn't make it back in time
okay great
representative loki did you have
something
i think perhaps uh it might be more
appropriate later when we get into
things
more technical than background
okay thank you
i'd also like to
welcome and thank senator ricciardi for
being here this morning
nice to see you
representative callie pitts i'd like to
know if there's anybody here or
contemplating coming on from the
municipal association
one of the things that i
i feel is very necessary is education of
um towns and municipalities so
just throwing that out
thank you i don't see anybody here from
the municipal association but
maybe they're watching from home
representative notter
i i saw a couple of hands raised in the
audience
senator ricardo has a comment on that
yes
good morning and for the record i'm
denise rashardi the senator for district
9.
i can't speak for the new hampshire
municipal association but i can
certainly speak for the town that i live
in which is bedford
and um
i was very instrumental in forming a
telecommunications committee in the town
and doing things that can help to
have all of our broadband which is
extremely important and all of our
technology because it's important to say
that
i don't believe anybody is saying we
shouldn't have it that we cannot go back
in time it's more about safer
sustainable technology and so we've been
able to put things in place
with safe setbacks and still maintain a
very good quality of broadband and at
some point if i can bring you lots of
information what we did how we did it
the ordinances that we put in we put it
on the ballot the people got to vote it
was done very well so hopefully that'll
thank you senator we appreciate you
bringing us up to date
okay so
who
in the audience
had raised their hand and wanted to
suggest a speaker to start with
anybody
simon
okay let's introduce that individual who
is
okay
doctor please take
a seat at the table and introduce
yourself
and spell your last name please
if i could pass these out
i have a powerpoint presentation which
is printed
for you
and the spelling is on it
l-a-p-i-n
um so
um my name is gregory lappin i'm a
i have a
doctorate in biomedical and electrical
engineering from northwestern university
and i'm a professional engineer in the
state of illinois
i
formerly was a research assistant
professor in neurology and biomedical
engineering
studying brain tumors
uh i'm a senior life member of the
institute of electrical and electrical
engineers which is ieee
and a member of
uh two of their committees one is the
committee on man and
radiation which we're
actually considering changing the name
to mankind and radiation
and
the international committee on
electromagnetic safety which
is the one that writes of one of the
major safety standards in the world
for rf exposure
i chair the american radio relay league
or arrl rf safety committee that's the
society of amateur radio operators
and i've
also worked over in england
on with their amateur radio operators to
help them
conform to the
i i sit on a committee at the fcc called
the technological advisory council
and i'm also a member of the national
fire protection association public
today i want to talk to you about
four topics
just
probably a review for many of you basic
electromagnetic principles but
why
we shouldn't be afraid of radio
frequencies and
how they fit into the broad range of
electromagnetic signals
the safety standards and the scientific
literature
because there are groups that have been
studying this for a long time and want
to make sure it remains safe
the applicability of the fcc regulatory
limits
which are based on those safety
standards
and then
a little bit about 5g what's different
about it than the cellular that we've
so
if you want to flip over to page four
let me start with the basic
electromagnetic principles
so
electromagnetics
covers everything down from
almost dc
within the engineering world we say dc
to light but it's
down to something with almost no
frequency
to the very very very high frequencies
which are which can be dangerous they're
all electromagnetic waves they all
physically
are similar to each other
but they have different frequencies and
it's the frequency that is the thing
that makes
the distinction between them
they're all called radiation because
they radiate they go from here to there
has nothing to do with danger it just
has to do with the fact that it can move
through space
for human health there's a major
distinction which lies somewhere around
ultraviolet light
frequencies below this are called
non-ionizing radiation and the
frequencies above are called ionizing
radiation
the ionizing radiation can damage tissue
by breaking apart molecules
which would include dna
and the non-ionization radiation really
can only interact with tissue by
generating heat
and on that
page five you can see
the way down at the lowest frequencies
our power lines are 60 hertz very low
we have radio the thing that says radio
is really fm radio there's am radio
below that
uh cell phones
of
that we've been using all along fit in
along there
you get up into the microwave region
where
radar is
and the frequency keeps increasing until
you get to light
visible light is also an electromagnetic
signal
just like a radio wave
except that our eyes can see it our eyes
are attuned to see those frequencies
and then through the light spectrum when
you get up to ultraviolet light that's
when it starts to be dangerous and we
know that because people worry about
skin cancer from being out in the sun
too long and we use
things that filter out those frequencies
from the
sun and then of course
higher and higher in frequencies it gets
more and more dangerous you have x-rays
which
you know
they're
not perfectly safe but they're necessary
for medical use
and then all the way up to gamma rays
so
when we communicate we try we try we do
stay below
the
limit of ionizing radiation so that
everything we use for communication is
non-ionizing
let's talk about electromagnetic
electromagnetic safety standards
so these are standards that examine the
scientific research to set human
exposure levels that have been shown to
be
safe the preeminent
emf standards are the ieee c95 that's
the one written by the ice committee
which i sit on
and ichnerp which is in
europe it's most of the european
countries follow that one the two are
very similar in their limits
and i'm going to talk mostly about c95
because that's the one i know best
in the u.s
ieee c95 is the basis for most of the
fcc regulations
standards examine experimental effects
of emf on laboratory animals and
epidemiological data
so the exposure limits
are then set to be 50 times lower
than the lowest exposure level that
could
on page seven
the ieee
c95.1 standard was the very first
electromagnetic standard
safety standard that was generated it
was initiated by the u.s navy and the
ieee in 1960.
the first version that was released the
first safety standard was in 1966 and
then versions were released in 17 1974
1991 1999 2005 and the latest in 2019
standards
are
developed by the ieee international
committee on electromagnetic safety isis
which i sit on
they're actually meeting right now
but
this this is their week for meetings and
they're
when i left them they were discussing
copyrights but uh
not something that
would
interest you all that much
um
this
the 1991 standard was the one which the
fcc regulations were based on
the fcc regulations were written in 1986
i'm sorry 1996
and the 91 standard was the latest for
them
it was the first version of the standard
that chose to vary the exposure limits
with frequency so prior to that one
exposure limit was used for all
frequencies
of course in time we are using more
frequencies than we used to
uh it covers the frequencies from three
kilohertz so very low frequency all the
way up to all the way up to 300
gigahertz
um
you know for
uh
that that's uh i don't know how to say
this to a non-engineer but three
kilohertz is 3000 hertz
300 gigahertz is 300 billion hertz
oh it hurts yes a hertz is a cycle per
second
and
we in the old days we used to call it
cycles for cycles
but now
they've named it after someone named
hertz
it was based on 498
publications of
scientific work in rf safety
and it even in the millimeter wave
region which is the one i'll i'll bring
up why that's important it had 11
publications this this is back in the
90s
and again its safety limits were set to
be 50 times lower than any level that
the literature said could cause
the latest version on page nine the
latest version of the standard is 2019 c
95.1-2019
and it's based on
high quality studies
now i say high quality studies because
it's important to realize that there's a
lot of literature out there that was not
science that was well done
and so
to
use the best science
each of those publications
was studied by five experts
um i i was one of those in fact
so
rough today there are roughly 5 000
publications on this topic
going all the way from power line
frequencies all the way up into the
gigahertz frequencies
so it's a wide range
but
to determine which of those were worth
using or
something we could trust
five experts in whatever the topic was
whether it's the low frequencies or the
high frequencies or
medical based
research
each independently read each of those
five thousand papers it was a little
less than five thousand back then but um
then they all voted on whether it was
good science or not and
the consensus of those five was used to
choose the 1550
of the best studies that were used to
determine what the standards would be
uh that re that review went all the way
back to 1950
and
uh
up till 2017 when the
standard was worked on
exposure limits were set by identifying
the levels at which any potential
harmful effects we're seeing so
previously it was based on heat heat
generation because that
was what was known to be
a danger
and then
at uh around 2005 they decided let's
look at everything that could possibly
cause any harm anything that mentioned
a biological change
look at the limit of exposure that
caused that and then again divide by 50
and set that to be the safety standard
the frequency range was also expanded
down to zero hertz or zero cycles per
second although and again up to 300
gigahertz
the safe exposure limits
that they came out with are very similar
to the ichner or the international
commission for non-ionizing
radiation protection in europe
they came out with a 2020 standard
and the limits are very similar they did
the two groups didn't work together but
they did
base it on the same science so it's not
this
just to show
who was working on developing those
standards
this these are the
back in 2006 that's when this
this statistic was made but these are
the people working on the standard
uh people from academia people from
government
uh
some people from industry some
consultants and even a couple from the
general public and all those people took
part in developing
on page 11
the fcc made regulatory limits now
unlike the science the regulatory limits
are based
are
are law
that's that's what
um manufacturers have to meet when they
generate
rf signals and they make phones
their phones have to meet those limits
in order
um the experience
since the regulations were originally
written in 1996 has shown that they are
sufficiently protective in 2019 the fda
concluded that no changes to the current
standards are warranted
based on their monitoring of public
health trends in other words they saw
that these limits
the american cancer society has
consistently shown no increases and many
decreases in the rates of most cancers
since cellular technology was first
introduced in 1985.
even
though this increase in cellular
cellular telephone use has grown
exponentially
no disease has increased
that might be related to it
and on the next page 12 that shows a
graph
that
indicates something like that this is
this is concentrating on glioma's brain
tumors
but it shows
in the uh
the blue line shows that the glioma rate
the the brain this that's the most
deadly brain tumor
um that's the one that has
been decreasing over time slightly it's
it's hasn't changed much but it's
slightly decreased
since 1985 all the way to 2015.
yet the number of cell phones in use has
exploded it has grown
[Music]
a great amount and even though these two
curves are plotted on
together
they have completely different
numbers
the
the blue line which is for the
gliomas represents approximately 27 000
new gliomas per year
the green line represents 380 million
cell phone subscriptions
at the end so even though they're
they're plotted on the same plot they
have very different numbers that they
represent
on the next page applicability of the
fcc regulatory limits
very large epidemiological studies have
shown no increase in disease among
long-time cell phone users
the national cancer institute showed a
drop in combined age-adjusted cancer
incident incidence rates from 1990
through 2016.
a time when the cell phone growth was
explosive
in 2011 an interphone study of 14 000
78 people in 13 countries
showed that there was no
cause of cell phones
no increase of cancer in cell phones
a danish cohort
cohort study of 358 403 individuals cell
phone users
over an 18-year period showed no
increase in disease and then in 2013
uh in england the oxford million women's
study uh
called the million women's study but
they only showed a little little less
than a million seven hundred ninety one
thousand
seven hundred ten female cell phone
all all cancer not just
one kind of cancer
from 1975 to 2016 showing that
cancer
during the time that cell phones have
been in
on the next page
the applicability of fcc regulatory
limits
is that worldwide health agencies have
consistently stated there there is no
danger of disease from cellular
technology with current limits including
5g
and this is just a list on this page of
all of the different
agencies health agencies
i have a question
yes oh okay go ahead
the statistic you've uh cited to us over
the last three or four pages all had to
do with cancer
or there are there any studies that
study that have looked at other health
problems that might have been caused by
cell phone
radiation and other
frequencies of radiation there have been
a lot of studies done and
to my knowledge not one of them has
shown
a
correlation
between any disease and the use of cell
phones
okay thank you i think
can and um
i think the uh
this this particular slide the the 15
i got a question for you sir um
i know the uh
the 2019
standard was set and no change from the
prior time that was set
but there was a lawsuit
in the uh district court of d.c
and the court said that
that the conclusions were arbitrary and
capricious
because
the the all the all the evidence was not
reviewed
and uh and that they had to go
they told the fcc to go back to the
drawing board
are you aware of that um
i'm not
i haven't read the case but i am aware
that the fcc did go back to the drawing
board and
i think they they upheld their
regulations
the implication was that not all the
science was looked at is the implication
from that is all i want to point out
thank you okay
and and when they did go back they have
been looking at
uh
as much science as they can get their
hands on okay thank you
representative
yes thank you thank you for taking my
questions
uh with your indulgence mr chairman uh
you said that the
ieee
standard is based on the 1991 version
of excuse me the uh
yeah the 1991 version of
ieee c95
is that correct
um safety standards ieee
95.1
uh and you said that uh
the current recommendation was based on
the 1991 version the current standard
that's what i wrote
what's the difference between the 91
standard and the
91 version and the several versions that
follow about the 2019
um the
the
uh there's very little difference in in
the standard um they they've not
found anything
that would uh give them evidence to
change
uh
say there's a health
problem
okay the fcc stand is based on uh the
most recent anyway 2019 you said is that
correct yes okay
um when you said you
researched you had five researchers
review all of the studies
and selected those that are you the five
people from various industries various
backgrounds viewed as credible what
criteria
how do you ensure that there is not
i'm not sure what you're asking the the
it's simple if you have five people who
believe in the stuff
and i'm not saying that's the case
you'll pick out ones that are that are
supportive of your of the viewpoint and
neglect the ones that are not supportive
uh and i'm not accusing anybody of that
but how do you ensure that there isn't
confirmation bias that it's based on
pure science
um just
that they look at all the science that
they can
it's um
i i
there's
a wealth of literature out there
and the
um
you know that people sit and
look over it and criticize it
uh
as much as they possibly can
and
in the lit they look at the literature
of what has been written scientifically
about it
and
come up with a decision on
if if someone comes out with a study
that says that
um
says that there's a disease
what the conditions were that would
cause that disease
and and
their
um
you know their conclusions have always
been that uh there is no not enough
evidence to show that that disease is
source
i have two questions that
occurred to me and i was writing them
down to wait till you were in the
presentation but i'll ask them now
one is was the has the cumulative effect
been studied in other words well my cell
phone is not a problem
affected by other sources and when we
look just at one
source
that may
precipitate a different outcome than the
cumulative effect that that's currently
going on
and i'm very simplistic
i know when i go down
the highway in certain places where
there's
high frequency say electric lines i
can't listen to my quote-unquote radio
because i don't have satellite and the
other question i'm just going to
dovetail it
um was there were two incidences that
that sparked my interest in this whole
subject
was one the evacuation of embassies and
i wanted to know if that was the same
because it was radio frequencies i do
believe that caused the evacuation of
some american embassies overseas and the
fcc's concern over engines
and of course all that was cleared and
supposedly but is that the same type of
radiation
well when you talk about
um
the when you talk
about say the embassies uh they were
being spun
i think you're referring to when the
embassies that were being spied on
so so some very high powered
signals were being sent in to do that
spying
are we talking about the same thing i
think we are and i i'm may i follow
follow up
was that the same type of frequency not
necessarily the same
intensity but the same types of
frequencies that we are all subject to
yes we're we're all subject to
a wide wide range of frequencies
so if um
but
the exposure level i think is what made
the big difference
in what you're referring to
that
and you're referring to the embassy
spying things the very high
could
cause a lot of damage to people
were being uh generated and does that
dovetail on our
cumulative exposure
daily
you know from from different things from
uh satellite dishes from everything in
our atmosphere i mean we seem to be more
and more dependent on you know bluetooth
and all these things
what is
does that take into effect the
cumulative um exposure that we all have
every day so at the lower frequencies
they don't
they're not
considered to build up in your body
they do not so there's nothing
radioactive radiation which which will
build up
but these are transitory they just
the the biggest effect that's been seen
that's the biggest damage that's been
seen they they
generate heat in your in your tissues
and
if the levels are kept low enough then
that
heat is not a dent
there's not enough heat is built up to
cause any danger
thank you thank you for taking my
question um
i was thinking about this uh as you were
going through the different things here
and as you're probably aware as long as
we've been studying radiation in fact i
know you're aware uh we've been debating
the linear no threshold model and
whether that's the most accurate one
nuclear news just had an article in it
last month about some guy said it was
absolutely not the correct way that you
get to a certain cut-off point where
there is no negative effect from
radiation
is this i'm and i'm not familiar with
the fcc stuff as well as i'm nuclear is
my
but is this based on that linear no
threshold model that you're assuming so
that any amount receives some damage but
it's just infinitesimally small or are
these based on a cut-off point when we
say below this radiation level there is
no damage
more of the latter
in
i think um
you're referring more to
uh ionizing radiation
radiation and so non-ionizing radiation
the damage that it creates is is heat
it generates heat and if
if your body can deal with the heat then
there's no damage
ionizing radiation
is very different it's different
but you're basing on the idea that
at a certain level that even if it's a
minuscule amount of heat generated and
we're not talking about much then there
really really isn't any damage to the
person is that the point of this um
unlike the ionizing radiation you're
saying but for the 9993 yeah
there is no linear no threshold model
it's you get to a certain point when it
it's low enough it doesn't have any
harmful effects it's at least measurable
that's exactly right okay thank you i
just wanted to make sure i got that
correct
uh yes dr lo
layton latman lapin okay uh apologize
for being late if i repeat any questions
i apologize for that if it wasn't
previously stated at the start of this
meeting
the purpose of the interim study is
basically to determine if there's any
reason for
follow-on legislative action in the in
the coming year
and the testimonies that we'll hear
in this meeting and if we have others
will determine if we need
legislative action
with that being said
my opening statement would have been
i believe all this information that
you're briefing was previously studied
in another
study and i did some research prior to
looking at this bill that came before us
this year and
saw the same results that that you're
stating now more or less you went into a
lot better detail of of course
and if i was to look at those studies
i would say no brainer this bill had no
bearing and we wouldn't be here now
but one
little thing
kept me thinking that we might
want to further discuss this and see if
something could be could come up with
perhaps something that wasn't in the
legislative statute but perhaps might be
something that might be done
on a
quasi-voluntary nature and that one
little something was
we kept hearing person after person
after person coming in here
complaining of
some type of ill effects not necessarily
disease
they couldn't correlate this cancer or
anything like that but headaches
disturbances
um things in their life that just wasn't
going weren't going right and they all
seemed to correlate around being near
this type of technology now we know and
we're not here to determine if any
disturbances
but there certainly appears to be a
correlation
with distance and proximity to this type
of technology so what we're really what
i really like to hear
if if not from you but perhaps other
speakers is
what
we we need to we need to acknowledge
that we have a lot of people in the
state that have had issues we need to
acknowledge that
not necessarily placing blame per se but
is there something
that this technology or the vendors of
this technology can look at
and
you know without going bankrupt
is there something that they can do to
help mitigate uh or look at these people
and say look if we if we went vertical
instead of horizontal or if went
horizontal instead of vertical
maybe this would help them even though
our stats kind of say
it doesn't appear to but perhaps
something could be done in that line of
work that's what i'm kind of looking for
here is some type of information that
could be done
without you know having to resort to a a
statute if if you will and and uh so if
there's anything that you could suggest
in your briefing or anyone else
following up on that it would be very
helpful just to hear that to see
just
because you're the experts and we want
to know i know engineers we can do this
way
the best way or maybe we can do it this
way it's a little more of an issue but
maybe it'll help solve this problem
over here that's how
i'm looking at this and so i'd like to
get your comments and thoughts on that
um
what i'm asking for is can you give us
any
potential solutions that we can look at
for
helping
people that seem to be susceptible i
know there's a small amount of them but
there are still out there that
that are having issues being near this
technology
i know i don't but i know people do
because they came before us and and and
they told us that's what we're not
saying blame i'm just saying is there
something that we can do to help help
them help mitigate something i i know
that the bill that we are studying here
talks about putting things at what 1700
feet away and i believe
it appears to be unacceptable to to the
vendors right
so
maybe there's something else we can look
at to help these people
uh
if you know what i mean you're referring
to
what what's often called
electrosensitivity
uh well if you want to label that i
believe that's what people are being
affected by yes okay but uh
perhaps
we want to hear from this representative
loki before he answers that thank you mr
chairman and thank you uh mr lapham um
i think one basic thing that we might
want to agree on is the you know what
happens with signal strength i know that
that thing i think is putting out 12
watts at i forget what the band is
now i'm receiving some amount of
radiation from that so are you so is
representative berezni now approximately
how much less energy is represented
rationally getting from that as compared
to myself
and how that changes with distance i
think that might be a useful thing to
start with
is
are you asking
[Music]
let me say it in words maybe i i i was
very clear
if there's
one way to
[Music]
do your
technology work as a vendor if there's
one place to put it versus another place
but that one place you're putting it
might be a little more sensitive to
people that may be overly reactive as
opposed to a different place
if you are able to do that different
place would you not choose that option
in order to help mitigate and and at
least uh accept the fact that some
people may be more more sensitive at
certain distances versus others
uh if
maybe you're not an engineer but but i
was i was just saying that i am an
insult okay i apologize since i was late
coming in here but but
being a being
with engineers my entire life i know
there's
the very best way there's 100 percent
word then there's 85 way i mean so i'm
i'm just saying
can we look at is it possible to look at
on a case-by-case basis positions of
antennas and so forth that might be
less desirable in one case but more
desirable in another case that's that
that's all i'm asking is something like
that that could be looked at
i'm i'm sure it could i'm not sure
there are a number of considerations in
a system design
and
i'm sure that those kind of things could
be considered
good
i know you and i chatted before this
subcommittee
about who you wanted to be here you
wanted representatives from the actual
industry
that from the three major companies to
be here
to have this discussion
i don't think
the the um
dr lapin
uh
is that i think he's a general
scientist engineer that consults i would
imagine
to different companies
uh is is on the is on the
uh what did you call it the fcc
technical advisory committee which gives
you a certain amount of uh knowledge of
what's going on behind the scenes there
which i find interesting
but i don't think he's i don't think
he's in a position to answer that
i i'm the i'm the gentleman who i'm the
gentleman who
who chaired the the 5g commission here
in the state
and i know i know we we we tried for a
long time to try to understand the
antennas and what's inside those
antennas
and how they're configured but none of
that's that's all proprietary
information
we could never get to that
um
but
i i
you know we were hoping for for the
industry i don't know if we really got
the industry here we got we got a
scientist which we appreciate an
engineer we appreciate
but
i don't know
i mean i i have some other comments
about let me let me mention one one
other thing uh when you and another
question for for him
is that
you you mentioned all the recent work
the signs that you that the your
committee looked at
but how about the national toxicology
program
um
30 million dollars program that's the
the national toxicology program is part
of the national science foundation
the government spent 30 million dollars
and came out with what a report that
said there is evidence of of certain
types of cancers due to due to
non-ionizing radiation
so i i would suggest that that you go
back to your group and say hey do we
look at this
uh and this is what we've been fighting
all along we've been fighting
the fcc it's very difficult for any
community any state any anyone
to battle the the
1996 uh
telecommunication act which gave
the industry free reign
and thereof there are
but okay i'm giving a speech so i i i
just i just hope you would carry that
message back to your group
uh that there are others there are a lot
of studies out there that are showing
non-ionizing effects
that are biological effects not just not
just heat heat's an old-school thing
it's it's beyond heat now there are
studies showing dna damage and and
they're showing cancers
so
i uh
and it is all about power density it's
all about power density and we don't
know what's coming out of those antennas
at all times we also have to watch out
for pulsing
the impacts of of pulsing
signals
uh things like that so um those are my
comments if you want to comment on any
of that i'd appreciate it thank you
okay so um please do
all right
so
um
are you saying that that
there's evidence of
of um
say
some diseases from
excuse me
levels
under the limits
yes there are
um
that's that's a whole discussion in
itself
but
um and that's why i think
that's why i think like i just said a
moment ago that
that
the
d.c district court said
that the results
of i would imagine your group
are arbitrary and capricious because all
the science wasn't studied the science
is there it's for you to study
uh and that's my comment
okay
i'm not a position right now to start
showing you examples of that there are
there are plenty of examples of that i
understand yeah
uh representatives um
do you have a question pertaining to
what was said so far or to what he's
what i what i thought i heard
the problem is that we were trying to do
is proximity is there a safe range where
we should stay away from these things
and that's very simplistic because my
brain works that way
that's all is there a range that if i'm
so close
i'm in more trouble or if i'm back and i
think that's further on in your
uh
in your presentation the other thing i
i guess a little bit
argumentative but if the courts
and everybody thought there was such
great danger that we haven't all been
exposed to right now
uh i don't know if there's been an
injunction placed against placing these
antennas and i don't believe so so i
just
i would like you to
see if you could
hone in on what we're trying to figure
out is a proximity
how far away do i stay or do i
head into outer space
thank you
um
well
there's no simple answer to that because
it's not the distance as much as as it
is exposure
so
different things transmit different
you know
not
this isn't germaine necessarily but
you hold your cell phone right next to
your head
and so that that's very close you're
you're much further away from
what the cell phone is talking to
and
and they transmit difference of
different amounts of power so you just
can't give one distance
as as the correct
answer
is
yes
to accept
uh representative thomas's chairman
thomas's statement that a tweak here or
there could somehow improve things you'd
have to have a basis
to begin with
that there's a problem right and you
don't
but but on the other hand i'm hearing
from
representative abrami that maybe you
didn't look at all the studies and and
so if you look at some of the studies
like the 30 million one would you reach
a different conclusion if not why not
we would have to look at that study and
discredit it for some reason or other is
that's what you were asking yeah um so
so the the safety standards do look at
all studies
and
comparing this one against that one to
see
what is the most reproducible and what
is the most uh believable
of
i'm not sure if that's a great answer to
your question
but
if i were to interpret that you did look
at this 30 million dollar
study and discredit it as not being
credible for
i didn't personally but i mean the group
a group looked at looked at all the
studies and and built a consensus
thank you i i think we've asked a lot of
questions here i'd like to have the
doctor continue with this presentation
so the
um
can you remember where i left off i was
on slide 10 um just showing the makeup
of
the
i must've i turned back i'm sorry
so
um
so i mentioned about the fcc regulatory
limits and then the uh
the different
agencies that
um and that there's a list here that you
can see
so let's get on
the 5g that um
that's that's a great catchword and it
really is a combination of communication
technologies
um it's 5g obviously stands for fifth
generation so cellular technology
it um
its claim to fame is it
advances the technology to provide
better performance than the previous
generations
higher speeds
better data transfer
and
it uses most of the same frequency bands
that the previous generations did and
adds a few more
and not all frequencies are used in all
locations
so if you go on to the slide 17
the
frequency bands used
for 5g
consist of a low low band region
a mid band region and a high band region
the
low band
was used from the very beginning
beginning of cellular technology
mid-band
came a little bit later it added more
more
data speed
and
you'll notice that as the bands get into
the higher and higher frequencies
they propagate
much shorter distances
um
a principle of of propagation of
frequencies so the
the low the low band
the cell towers were placed further
apart because they they could
talk further but in those low
frequencies
not as much data could be transmitted
and then a mid band was added
with
the 2g 3g and 4g
uh
iterations of cellular
and then the high band is the
real addition to the
5g
and it
pretty much propagates very short
distances
so
as we go
you find that the low band because it'll
propagate longer distances you find it
more in rural areas
and often the towers are very high
because it can get down to the ground it
can
um
reach the long distance and lots of
lots of users can make use of that those
low band frequencies
the mid band and it's also called sub
six gigahertz
um is
good in most locations and it has a good
balance between data transfer rates and
and
the density of cells by density i mean
how close you have to put the different
cell towers
or
transmitter receivers
and then the high band which is also
called millimeter wave
um is for is really used in very densely
populated areas
so it's areas that need
high data transfer rates
and
um
that have lots and lots of people
because all those people have to share
the same frequencies to get their data
transferred
so you need you get a very high transfer
so if
you can go to
slide 19 that's just a pictorial of
the frequencies that these different
bands are located in
the
low band
uh mid-band and high band
and they
they still
set well below
um ionizing radiation or
where you get to uv light and higher
and that's that's a pretty important
uh point to any
person looking looking at physical
effects because
the
signals sent from any of these bands
don't have the energy to ionize they
don't have the energy to create
to break down
anything like dna or any
cells or chemicals
which obviously is very important
because those are the ones
those breakdowns are the ones that
start to cause some of the diseases
on uh
small cells are
something that are a little bit newer um
we're
all familiar for many years with the
very high cell towers
and the cell cells that are on top of
big buildings
that cover wide areas
but as you saw with the different
frequencies some of them don't travel as
far
so you have to be able to
um put more cells in and those are
called small cells
in order to get
the signal to travel in sufficient
strength to be used by the people in
that area
another thing that small cells do which
existed before
was to fill in gaps let's say you have a
high cell tower but
there's a big building that makes a
shadow that the people on the other side
of that building can't get any service
so you could put a small cell in that
building that would just
um
small cell is also good for providing
more high speed data
in a in a small cell you have fewer
people that are being serviced so
the sharing of the data that's going
over those frequencies is less so each
person gets more
if there are more users in a service
area than can be handled
so
say in a city region a very dense city
where
a
high cell
just has so many people in its area that
they they can't share those frequencies
adequately
then you can
supplement it by adding small cells that
will
and of course as i said previously when
you get get up to millimeter waves
and you have very high data rates the
signals just can't travel far enough to
be effective
so you need a small cell
to be close to the people that are using
it
now one thing that
um
with with these increasing frequencies
one of the advantages that we
uh realized
is that we could make smarter antennas
antennas that point right to where
they're talking
and
give less
radiation to other people around it
not that that radiation would be
dangerous but it just
is a more efficient way of transmitting
you don't have to use as much power
you can direct all the power at the
people that you're talking to
so
the going back like pre-cellular
antennas sent their signals in all
directions
and i use the example of a whip antenna
on a police car
when that police car drives by
when it transmits its signal is going
so no matter where you stand on that 360
degree circle
the newer antennas are called multiple
input multiple output or mimo
you may have heard that term
and they use lots and lots of different
antennas that are
phase related and that phasing of the
antennas allows them to direct beams
in different directions
which focuses the signal
what that gives is
more power
to the signal that
to the direction
that it needs to be to the cell phone
that is talking to it
and much less to people who are just
so
the major exposure is the person that's
communicating but because
it
jumps around that exposure doesn't last
so
it can be
for a few milliseconds pointing to you
and then it'll jump over to someone else
and because the frequencies are very
high the data rates are very high
so
if your phone if you're talking into
your phone and this is happening
so fast that you don't realize it
it can buffer up or hold on to some of
your speech
and then dump all that at the very high
frequency over to the cell when the cell
is pointing at you
so it's not real time it's not
hearing
always what you say as you say it
and again this is a
millisecond ranges so you don't realize
this
but
it
allows you to concentrate your energy
for very short time
to get all the data or the voice
information from a person that's talking
and then move on to the next person and
the next person and so on
and it moves around that way it's um
that's where the phrase multiple input
that's okay
and then
you know the advantage of that is that
other locations around that antenna
receive very little exposure
because it's only
exposing
what it who it needs to expose and then
only for a short time
whereas you know going back to the
the old antennas like the whip antenna
on the police car
that's exposing lots of people that
technically don't need to be exposed
the police cars talking in a direction
say toward the police station and
someone standing on the opposite side
doesn't really need to be exposed to
anything from that police car but that's
the way that technology works
so as a result those power levels have
to be much lower to make sure that no
we have another speaker that came here
specifically and i'd like to him as soon
as i can so if without uh objection if
you'd like to just continue here no
problem either way go ahead
um
so the the mimo antennas work best at
higher frequencies and that's because of
the wavelengths um
not to get to engineering
technical
uh
at a higher frequency your antenna can
be smaller and you have
smaller antennas you can put lots of
them together and then you can phase
them so that you can direct the beam
so at mid band
the the mimo antennas have very few
elements because the wavelengths are
larger so they just can't fit as many
and the focused beam is fairly wide
and then as the frequency increases the
number of antenna elements can then
increase and
at millimeter wave antennas can have
hundreds of elements and and the phrase
for that is massive mimo or little m
mimo
when you see that
they're
phasing the signal to each of those
elements differently so it
it generates a well focused
beam of radio frequencies
and that allows the small cells then to
decrease their power they don't need as
much power if they're not wasting it
going in other directions that aren't
needed
and
they get the same coverage that way
and on the slide 23 there's a pictorial
of what i just described
um on the left
there's a police car with a little
antenna on it and people
on a circle all around it are all
getting the same exposure
from that police car now that's i'm not
saying that's a problem
to the police car because they don't use
as much power
so it's it's not i'm not pointing that
out as a problem that's just an
inefficiency
uh the the mimo
antennas at mid-band
can't don't have as many elements so
they can't focus as effectively
and
but they point to a region
and that's an improvement certainly
so they can transmit less power because
they're it's all going into that region
and then
on the right the massive mimo with lots
of elements
generate very narrow
fairly narrow beams
talking to each person
and ident just
for the graphic graphical purposes i use
the light pole because many of these
a millimeter wave is the highest
frequencies and the stuff that's new in
5g
and
uh so it's new in 5g but is it really
new
such that we don't know anything about
it and that answer to that is no
frequencies in the tens of gigahertz the
millimeter waves have not been used in
cellular telephony before
but they have been used by the military
for a very long time
and the safety standards have always
been developed with military input
usually
they are the first ones out there to
work on the safety standards
the research studies on millimeter wave
interactions have been performed for a
long time uh so in 1986 there was a
study
but you might know the name gandhi from
uh las vegas
from the university of nevada
uh he and ryazi measured the penetration
depths for different frequencies and at
30 gigahertz is
excuse me which is one of the
millimeter wave frequencies being used
in 5g
he measured that the signal goes
penetrates about 0.8 millimeters into
the skin so it doesn't go through your
whole body it gets stopped
that is one of the the features of well
i don't know if the feature but one of
these
characteristics of those high
frequencies that they don't penetrate as
well they get stopped by things
on slide 25
as the frequencies get higher they
approach the frequency of visible light
which is something that our bodies have
adapted to
so the frequency of red light which is
is about 10 000 times higher than the
millimeter wave frequencies that cell
phones are using
for comparison
those
millimeter waves are about ten thousand
times higher than am radio frequencies
so and also the exposure is very
different if you stand out in the full
sun
you get a higher exposure than
millimeter wave safety standards
and i i just threw in a little comment
make sure you wear your uv sunscreen
sunlight gets into ionizing radiation
which radio waves do not
so the uv
is part of the sunlight
whereas
it certainly is not part of any anything
that a cell cellular radio would send
um but by comparison the fcc millimeter
wave exposure limit is 10 milliwatts per
square centimeter and you can be exposed
to 100 milliwatts per square centimeter
10 times that
so we're
moving on to
slide 26
where
let me summarize
so
after many years of use by the majority
of the people on the planet
cellular telephone use has not increased
the incidence of any disease in the
population
5g introduces something new the
millimeter wave frequencies to cellular
telephony million millimeter waves have
been used by the military for many years
and they have
commissioned studies that have not shown
any damage to those
the safety standards that have proven to
be protective to society and by that i
mean
epidemiologically there's
they are
shown that there's no increase in
disease
from those cell standards
they have conservative limits for a
millimeter waves
in other words much less than you would
have received from standing out in the
sun
and the
massive mimo antennas which are used for
these highest frequencies
greatly reduce the exposure to
bystanders from millimeter waves from
small cells they point right to who
they're talking to and they jump around
they don't spend much time because they
can
transmit data at such high rates and by
data i mean your voice becomes data when
you're talking into a phone so
your voice is part of the data or or if
you're using your phone for the internet
whatever that data is
um
it gets packetized it gets put together
and it's instead of real time it gets
dumped up to the cell
all at once
so it it doesn't have to point at you
on slide 27
as communications frequencies continue
so light is is also composed of
electromagnetic energy just like
cellular it's all electromagnetic energy
down to am radio all the way up into
light
millimeter wave interactions with human
tissue are similar to that of light they
don't penetrate far below the upper
surface of the skin
and we're regularly exposed to much
higher levels from the sun
than are allowed from millimeter waves
and let me clarify something again
we're exposed to a lot more from the sun
than we are from a cellular tower
the sun
has ionizing energy in it and that's why
you get a sunburn
uh you won't get a sunburn from anything
from your radio because there's no
ionizing energy you won't get cancer
from non-ionizing energy
fcc exposure limits
follow the safety standards that have
and that's that's the end of my formal
presentation
if there are any other questions i'll be
happy to answer them
um well thank you for an excellent
presentation i i appreciate you coming
here and giving us this
very technical and interesting
dissertation on frequencies which i
think is very important to know anyway
uh we do have a time constraint in that
we have a person here that came this way
i'll allow me one or two quick questions
with some quick answers sure
representative platt thank you you
referred to the towers and you refer to
the low band towers being far apart and
big
then the mid band towers closer together
not doesn't have to be as big and the
high band towers have to be close but
fairly small you sell you use the term
cell would you consider sort of a cell
phone
uh a uh
in other words you're talking to towers
but a cell phone also propagates does it
not
um the cell phone talks to the towers
yes
so so i mean we all have cell phones
most of us is there a problem there
um well i guess that's not really the
this point of discussion but those
things are studied together so
the answer is no there's not a problem
there because this the energy in the
cell phone is kept low enough
the last question represents here i'll
try to make this quick just one comment
uh you keep uh a number of times you
stressed on the military doing this in
the past
i mean i've seen documents from the
military where people were actually able
to see the bones in their hands and
their arms because they're being exposed
to radiation uh when they were doing
nuclear testing in the in the 1950s so
now these militaries doesn't necessarily
give me a
warm up feeling there but i'm i want to
get back to this a linear knoll
threshold because you seem to be saying
no that doesn't apply if it's
non-ionizing radiation there's no damage
then why are we spending so much time
covering the amount of exposure i mean
it's sort of like
me tapping on the table here i can do it
for 50 years and my finger is not going
to go through it but why do i bother
keeping count of how many times i tap
then okay i'm sorry if i was unclear
that um there can be
damage from non-ionizing radiation
uh it's a different type
it's heat generated so if the non
if the non-ionizing radiation generates
too too much heat
it can damage your tissues and inside
your body is held to a very
tight uh temperature limit
this real quick so there is a limit but
we the debate is where that limit is yes
okay thank you
dr levin are you 11 are you
uh planning to leave right away or can
you stay for a while
um i
can be here
early afternoon
okay uh then
if if if you don't mind standing by i'd
like to call up another
uh briefer and appreciate you coming by
and hopefully we can have some more
questions for you later on
i have here uh mr james hancock who has
come here especially to speak and i i
know you have a time constraint so
apologize for being a little late but
thank you for coming
my pleasure and uh i'm happy to be here
so whatever i can do to help
so i'm james hancock i'm from
chesterfield new hampshire i have
extensive background uh working with
cell phone companies uh and the
companies that produced the technology
uh that did dsl services and things like
this and uh you would think that cell
phone technology and dsl and network
cables uh and all these things and even
the light bulbs in a room
uh all are different well they're not
a really brilliant gentleman i can't
remember his name at the moment uh
developed a technology that creates a
wave that we think of a wave as a sine
wave right but what he actually
recognized is that the best way to block
against interference is to broadcast a
positive one and a negative one at the
same time so if we want to have an on a
binary we would broadcast both a
positive and a negative frequency
of the same thing okay and then if we
wanted to zero we would broadcast
nothing and you could go and use a
mathematical formula to eliminate all of
the interference in the air okay and
this technology is in your usb cable
that you use to plug in your phone or
plug your printer into your computer
this is in every single computer for
every single communication and every
single computer it's used it's called
pulse width modulation and various
different versions of it are used in
light bulbs so every one of these leds
uses tiny amounts of voltage but to get
that tiny amount of voltage from the
wall socket it uses pulse width
modulation at kilohertz and even
megahertz to bring the voltage down
and to be able to provide you the light
you you receive with an led light bulb
so everywhere around us right now is
pulse width modulation and what 5g and
even 4g and 3g are is a version of
broadcasting both a positive and a
negative
frequency of radio waves
so that it can go and create this signal
as our steam guest before us talked
about he talked about memo and all these
things
those things are all great technologies
and they'll go to my second point in
this but really what we're fundamentally
talking about is pulse width modulation
literally every single thing that you
interact with in the world today that
isn't your oven
uses pulse width modulation if you have
a ground source heat pump or an air
source heat pump or an air conditioner
they're emitting
pulse width modulated waves and in fact
the fcc regulates those in exactly the
same way that they regulate your cell
phone and cell phone towers and in fact
if i take a frequency measuring device
and i hold it over as an example the
brick for your your laptop that you plug
into the wall that converts ac power to
dc i will get exactly the same type of
signal close to the power brick as i do
my cell phone
okay so
and it will look exactly the same if i
hook it up to an oscilloscope it will
look exactly the same
okay because there's no difference
they're literally all the same
technology
okay so it's very very important to
understand this and to understand that
when we actually look at 5g what 5g
actually is which is an encoding
standard it's how the the ones and zeros
are encoded it's not the frequencies it
on it's on the only difference between a
5g signal
and a 4g signal is how often it checks
for errors in the message
and they all they did was they delay the
number of error checks that occur in the
signal by 30
which increases the amount of bandwidth
in any given frequency by about 30
percent because they get rid of the
error checks real literally imagine say
making a sentence
and broadcasting across a string and you
want to say did you hear me right
and the person on the other end repeats
back what they heard
that's effectively what's happening and
the less you can do that while still
getting the signal across the faster you
can communicate information so when we
look at lte or 4g or 3g or even 2g
okay they're all broadcasting in exactly
the same way
they slightly change how the information
is grouped together within that pulse
width modulation
and they change how often it checks for
errors
but between 2g 3g 4g and 5g on the same
frequency there's no difference
and just as importantly you could put a
2g signal
in what our steam guest called
millimeter wave
at very high frequencies 38 48 28 12
gigahertz you could easily broadcast 2g
in those frequencies there's no reason
why you wouldn't except we've developed
much better ways of doing it so it's
more efficient to use 5g to in those
frequencies than it is to use 2g okay so
and
just as vitally if we look at
frequencies and this is the vital thing
that we need to understand in this
conversation is that as technology
improves
we broadcast less
we get quieter as a human race
specifically because our technology is
improved consider wmur that's
broadcasting right now
okay in the same frequencies that
t-mobile has 5g
okay and they're broadcasting a digital
television channel which uses pulse
width modulation which is just a variant
of lte at the time when it was developed
okay it's broadcasting right now right
at you using exactly the same technology
exactly the same wave in exactly the
same format because it's digital when
the digital transformation happened it's
broadcasting at 50 000 watts of power
that's 50 kilowatts
your cell phone in that same range is
less than one watt
one watt
okay
one okay so even
where 35 40 miles from from wmurrow's
tower you're still getting over a
kilowatt of energy
in those same frequencies hitting your
body right now and it's at a frequency
that goes through walls
okay so it's hitting you right now and
by the way has been hitting you your
entire lives
okay with no change
did anybody care about the television
channel that was broadcasting or the
radio channels because radio has gone
digital so every single radio channel
has uses the side of their frequencies
they made their their regular analog
frequency for old radios uh sound worse
and they use the side frequencies for
digital well it made it vastly more uh
capable of hold carrying data
but its pulse width modulated data so
literally every single radio station in
the state is broadcasting at least a
carrier wave and most of the time
they're broadcasting at least one
probably two
digital radio frequencies and they're
using exactly the same technology as
cell phone service does to do it and
they're broadcasting at 50 000 watts
on average there's a few that are lower
okay but that's coming into you all the
time
now how many have heard about starlink
elon musk starlink from spacex i think
everybody right
starlink is in 12 gigahertz
okay
so with the exception of millimeter wave
5g
that is vastly higher frequency than all
other
cell phone communication we're talking
just recently the fcc just approved 3.5
gigahertz for cell phone service okay so
we're talking at least three times more
higher
well right now concord where we're
sitting is in serviced area by starlink
at 12 gigahertz and i just looked it up
before i got in here it's at 66 db which
works out to 4.16
kilowatts of power
broadcasting that's hitting us right now
so as soon as you go outside no matter
what this committee does
no matter what any actions are taken
here because you have no control over
starlink you're getting orders of
magnitude more radiation hitting you
from the starlink satellites than you
are from any cell phone or any cell
phone tower because an average cell
phone tower in the united states
broadcast between 100 and 300 watts and
it's really rare to see any one of them
over 200 watts and
if you're talking about millimeter wave
they're less than half of that
so the higher the frequency according to
the fcc regulations the lower the
broadcast power so if i'm in
low band okay 700 megahertz 800 900
megahertz we're talking one to two watts
if i'm in mid band so 1700 megahertz to
about 26 2700 megahertz typically
sometimes up to three depending on who
you talk to we're talking a half a watt
of power that your cell phone's
broadcasting okay and the telephone
towers broadcast at half the power
because
they understand that the higher the
frequency the lower the power level has
to be so when we go and put those
numbers in perspective because just
above elon musk's starlink
is a form of phased pwm
used by noaa for weather satellites
they're broadcasting down on you and
they're broadcasting at 15 times more
power than starlink does
on your bodies and have been since 1979.
the world gets a massive benefit from
those towers those satellites because we
know when a hurricane's going to hit we
didn't know these things before unless
somebody flew a plane and happened to
spot one and could report it but we have
these things now and we have it because
of this technology which is pulse width
modulation so
the the key here is is that everything
in this room
the entire world i mean i don't know
whether any of you saw uh what's called
the current wars the movie between the
war between tesla and edison between ac
and dc power
everybody says that tesla won that war
because ac one
except actually he won a battle
the entire world is dc literally
everything in this room if it consumes
electricity
is dc power and dc power is run off
pulse width modulation
okay so
every single thing we do uses exactly
the same thing so there have been claims
to this committee in the past that i've
heard they're disingenuous saying that
5g is different than lte or 2g or
different than a network cable it's not
they're identical okay and i'll stress
that there's been claims that well we
could ban 5g
um because it really just uses lte for
its sending of data anyway so it doesn't
matter that's not true anymore
t-mobile's already turned on uh
stand-alone 5g which means that
and it's all over the state already by
the way you can go to cellmapper.net and
you can go and look at t-mobile's
coverage for for
new hampshire and there's 5g all over
the state and it's standalone it does
not use lte
lte will be phased out within the next
six or seven years because it's not like
2g it's not a foundational protocol that
requires voice
so the reason why 2g stayed around so
long is because we didn't have a way of
actually sending voice communication
over 3g so it skipped an entire
progression
before it got to lte and we could do
voice over lte so we had to when we were
3g you had to have 2g still
so it lasted from the mid 1990s all the
way to this year
but that won't happen with lte we're
talking five to seven years at most
before they start decommissioning lte
because there's simply no reason to
because 5g handles voice and it's
completely standalone so if you ban 5g
you're banning the future of the of cell
phone technology and if you expect the
cell phone companies to expend the money
in new hampshire to support legacy
technology that likely won't even be
built within the next 10 years they
won't actually build lte radios
then you're going to send new hampshire
back into the stone age very very
quickly as as the broadcast towers stop
working and the cell phones stop
supporting lte so it's just a matter of
time before a decision made
based on false assertions
is going to cost new hampshire
technology and a technology lead and all
of the things that come with technology
but
the the key point here and we going back
to wmur as an example
okay we watch tv over the airwaves at 50
000 watts
we watched their digital television at
50 000 watts
now on our cell phones with a half a
watt in our pocket and less than 200
watts at the cell phone tower that's at
a distance
we're watching television you can watch
wmur on your cell phone over your lte
and 5g connection at thousands of times
less
radiation hitting your body
okay this is true throughout history so
most people don't realize this but when
spot nick went up
it broadcast at like 5 000 megawatts of
power to get a single signal through
okay so the history of human endeavor to
do with radios is to make them more
efficient and less radiating
everything gets less and less radiating
and more and more quiet
so if you ban this technology
you're literally stopping the very thing
that is going to actually improve the
health of people if you were to believe
that there's actually something wrong
with the technology and that's dangerous
you're literally banning the technology
that lessens the amount of radiation
you're receiving from these devices
you're not actually stopping the
radiation they're just going to use the
more radiative version of the old
technology and as our steam member said
nemo
limits your radiation even more
it makes it even more efficient and it
has less and the one last thing that i'd
like to mention so everybody asks well
these radio waves they do generate
radiation uh and they they do cause a
side effect of heat that was just the
question it was asked this is an
important thing to talk about
think of a bucket of water
or a pot of water on your stove right my
my wife my daughter who's watching us
right now
they were just talking about this the
other day they were talking about why is
the pot not boiling over
right and my wife says it's because she
turned the temperature down
okay so she reached an equilibrium where
it was boiling but it was not boiling
all over the place okay
the important part there is that our
bodies and everything around us
radiate heat at a specific level well
the fcc knows exactly what that is the
fda knows exactly what those numbers are
with specificity in every single human
body okay so all of the input that goes
in with the energy of these waves that
generate heat
it would have to be higher than what our
bodies can radiate that heat back out at
to actually cause damage from the heat
it wouldn't cause damage from the actual
radio waves because the universe has
been spewing radio waves in exactly
these frequencies and continues to do so
at multiple levels higher than what we
have today
the key is it would have to broadcast it
and generate so much focused energy in a
specific spot where it actually heated
your skin faster than your skin could
radiate the heat
right so if you've ever gotten a sunburn
when you burn your skin's really hot
well a large part of a sunburn is
actually caused by the fact that the
solar rays the
ultraviolet is so powerful that it's
super heating your skin
and your skin can't release the heat so
most of the damage most of the peeling
from a sunburn actually happens as a
result of the fact that your skin gets
so heated so quickly by those radio
waves the light waves that are hitting
you that it causes the damage it isn't
actually the uv that's causing that the
uv breaks apart dna but it's actually
the heat generated that causes
everything that we normally associate
with with a sunburn okay so it's exactly
the same thing with radio waves the
difference is is that at the levels
we're talking about it's 10 times less
than what the equilibrium point is
okay so if you think about this right so
if you've got your your oven in it or
your your stove top and it's got to dial
to 10
okay and let's say seven is where it
keeps boiling but it doesn't boil over
and if you went to eight it would boil
over
your and you equate this to your cell
phone it's on less than one
okay
less than one so the water isn't even
getting lukewarm
it would take over two hours of you on
your phone with it pressed against your
face
before you would even notice any heat
and i guarantee most of the heat you
would notice is simply because the cell
phone itself trapped the heat against
your skin that your body was already
radiating
okay so it's vitally important to
understand these things
and it's vitally under important to
understand that the technology behind 5g
is no different than the technology
behind 4g and everything that came
before there's nothing unique about it
at all
okay so questions
represent kelly pitts
again with my very simplistic mind if
the technology is the same
why won't
some of the devices
work
right so they weren't designed for it so
um you there's there's a hardware and a
software component okay so if you look
at the way a radio is built you're
talking about a thing that's is
fluctuating millions of times a second
okay so if we go and look at a cell
phone it's fluctuating millions of times
a second and to do that they can't do it
in software to control it they have to
use a hardware algorithm okay so the
hardware itself generates the
fluctuations because the software can't
run fast enough to do it so if i was to
go and create a radio they're called
software to find radiators you can buy
them
to be able to go and generate an lte or
5g signal in lower mid band i can do
this you can buy these that are off the
shelf and you plug your computer in okay
your cell phone has a chip that uses a
few watts of power
that same software-defined radio doing
the work that your cell phone is doing
will use about a kilowatt of electricity
and require the very fastest computers
uh that you can buy from your local best
buy will barely be able to keep up with
the processing necessary to drive that
radio so each one of these cell phones
has a specific piece of hardware that
its only job is to actually control the
broadcast and reception of those signals
because otherwise it would generate
consume so much electricity nobody be
able to have them in their pockets
that's why the original bag phones were
so huge and they plugged into 12 volt
and they used to even pop the breakers
in your 12 volt cigarette lighter and
the reason why is because they were
right at the limit of the cigarette
lighters
fuse because they were drawing so much
power to be able to process it well
we've gotten so much better at building
them in hardware that they're they use a
lot or less but the problem is is that
every single time you do that is
specialized
for the technology at that moment as
soon as a new technology comes out a new
frequency they have to go and build a
new specialized version that will handle
those new frequencies that's why they
become obsolete
and part of that's quite honestly they
want to sell you a new cell phone so
they will actually design the cell
phones in a specific way so that they
can apply that later okay
i can i follow it i just wanted to say
that my 1960s transistor radio works
fine
for now
for now until they turn off analog radio
i'm going to go with representative wiki
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh you talked about uh wmur transmitting
50 kilowatts and you said one kilowatt
would get to us now is that each of us
as an individual the whole city of
concord uh
it just uh it seems like an awful lot of
energy going into me if i'm getting a
whole kilowatt i'm gonna cook um so how
would you
separate that out is uh so so power
levels over the air in open air with no
interference so no trees no walls
nothing uh it uses the inverse
proportion of square law okay so for
every meter because it's all in metric
for every meter the power will drop by
the square of the square root of the
of the frequency okay so i did a back in
the napkin calculation using an online
calculator i took three of them just so
i made sure that i wasn't using a wonky
one or something like that and i looked
at the distance from here there to here
from where the tower is and golf down to
here okay and came up with because it's
an omnidirectional antenna so if you go
and look at the fcc's diagrams for wmur
you'll see off the top of that big stick
it's broadcasting relatively evenly
relative to train
a signal that's in basically a circle
okay or a cone that shape that uh fires
downwards okay and that's true of every
single radio tower except for early am
radio that we're in a phase three three
tower array um
they're all basically omnidirectional as
said before okay so everybody's getting
an equal part of all of that radiation
okay um and it's hitting you and because
it's so low frequency it's going through
the walls and
the higher the frequency so if you
double the frequency it will penetrate a
solid object the same solid object half
as much okay yes there are details and i
apologize to the sinus in the room
because i'm simplifying but effectively
if you take the same piece of concrete
and double the frequency it will go half
as if it's far through or if it does go
through the concrete it will be half as
powerful
uh thank you um where does the one
kilowatt go does it go to the whole city
of concord does it go to
you you said 50 kilowatts out that says
50 parts total there and then you said
something about one kilowatt i'm trying
to understand where that one kilowatt
goes
so concord based on its distance open
air directly from the tower we'll get
about one kilowatt right about here i
just took the middle of the state house
okay but if i was five miles down the
road it would be less than that
if i was in the lakes region it would be
ten times less than that
okay but if i'm in manchester
it's significantly more than a kilowatt
okay so the closer you are to the tower
the stronger it is but interestingly
with towers they actually broadcast like
this so if you're standing at the base
of the wmur tower you're probably not
even going to be able to receive the
channel
i just want to thank you mr hanson for
teaching me how to write while you were
speaking at 5g speeds
sorry
i know you guys are packed so i try to
speed up so
harrington
um
i guess my question would be and i don't
know if you have any answer to this or
not but
it seems as if we're being inundated by
all types of radiation constantly uh of
all different frequencies and
wavelengths
and
now we're trying to hone in on this one
particular thing cell phones is it did
you have any concept of percentage-wise
in other words if we were to make cell
phones go away completely
how much would that reduce the overall
uh radiation burden that we're absorbing
uh as people would that be
2 any ideas i can't give you an exact
number but
um
we're talking like one one trillionth of
one percent
with the majority of that coming from
the sun i'm assuming the sun cosmic
radiation x-rays
you know if a supernova goes off
and when it hits the earth you'll get a
hundred million times more radiation
than you will in your entire life
otherwise as an example so
if you take all of those sources and
then you take
natural radiation sources all over the
globe that happen lightning strikes even
friction in the air is generating radio
frequencies when you take the totality
of that
plus all of the other noise that we have
from
nuclear reactors
you name it even coal
[Music]
fire plants will generate radiation
that's a pet peeve of mine they actually
can be they can emit more radiation than
a nuclear plant can legally admit but
that's another issue exactly right if
you take in the totality of everything
that's going on it's minuscule because
just consider the number of computers
that are in this building
okay and they're they're
you're sitting right beside it you're
sitting in front of a screen probably
this far away if you just consider
that's broadcasting more radiation than
your cell phone is
okay so you know and yes
you have to be specific that those are
different types
and a lot of that might be x-rays and
they might be uv ray maybe visible light
and stuff like this but we're talking
about the most safe type of radiation
okay we're talking about the least
damaging radiation that a hundred plus
years of evidence proves i mean ben
franklin was literally doing experiments
on this stuff okay so we've had a lot of
experience with this and there's no
evidence that this isn't the most safe
form of radiation that you can
experience a quick follow-up
um i know you're not a medical doctor
but you've obviously been associated
with the cell phone and radiation for
quite some time you know we have people
coming in here telling us
absolutely it's safe if you stay below
these limits it's you know 50 times less
than anything that's going to hurt you
et cetera et cetera that we get other
people coming in and saying i'm sick
from cell phone towers do you have any
plausible is there an explanation of
that have you heard anything that would
uh lead us to understand why certain
people at least believe they're very
sick because of this so first of all i
hold five patents in epidemiology i
wrote the software that's used for all
distributed epidemiology in the united
states through the fda through the
sentinel program you can look me up i
stand corrected you much more qualified
to answer the question than i thought so
by all means do i i am not a medical
doctor i am a statistician okay and i've
written statistical analysis that goes
directly to epidemiology um so one there
there's two issues when you look at
statistics
that really throw people for a loop and
i'm going to use an example i'm going to
use the dirty word in the room it's
called ivermectin
when we look at the studies that have
been done on ivermectin the reason why
you'll find 15 studies and i'll draw 15
separate conclusions
is specifically because of what's called
a multivariant problem
the same thing occurs with vitamin d
okay so you have to control for all the
variables
okay and when we're talking about
radiation it's effectively impossible so
if anybody's ever tried to uh go and
look at their vitamin numbers
all right they go and get a vitamin test
done to see exactly what their levels of
vitamin are
and then they try and modify their diet
to try and address those numbers and
they completely and utterly fail
okay and almost everybody does the
reason why is because there's so many
moving variables including even men's
time of the month will affect a male's
values for their vitamin deficiency or
otherwise okay even the time of day will
change those numbers so it's almost
impossible to control these things
because there are so many variables okay
so if i look at one study on on
radiation non-ionizing radiation and i
look at another one it could be
you know so as an example your microwave
uses 2.4 gigahertz which is right in the
middle of mid band it's broadcast in a
way like crazy right
well it boils water
okay so it has a deep effect on water
it doesn't have a deep effect on
anything else because that's not the
harmonic frequency that if you vibrate
the thing at it won't boil water right
well but if i use 2.6 i could boil
something else you can literally
turn aluminum into liquid if you fire
the right radio waves at the right right
frequency and the right strength you can
literally melt it
right you can do the same thing with
mercury or any other element they all
have a sympathetic frequency so just
changing it slightly will change your
results they may not be meaningful but
they'll change your results and this is
the important part of epidemiology is
that we look at the totality of the
evidence from multiple different levels
an average out and this is the same
thing in climate change data and other
other fields we try and average out the
noise to try and eliminate those false
positives and false negatives and it's
called the p rate okay so you'll see
this in in studies all the time they
call the it's called the p rate and
that's the uh estimation using a really
really really tight formula of how much
noise could be affecting
your results
okay if you look at the p rate of most
of these studies it is embarrassingly
low
okay meaning that it is very very very
low confidence that there isn't other
noise in the numbers that's why you get
this and then you also win please
interrupt but i'm trying to get back to
the do you know of any reason these
people are not dealing with statistics
they're dealing with their health they
say i mean i've got a
piece here from a woman from my town who
says she has her blood treated and all
this other stuff she's run up 80 000
worth of bills and she claims it's all
because of exposure to cell towers and
that's why she moved is there any
can you know of of why these things are
happening
other than you know i don't think this
person's making up her illness but
is there anything out there that you've
heard of because you've obviously very
experienced in the field so there's no
scientific evidence anywhere and i
scoured before i
do this testimony and i
really really work hard to try and
understand all the perspectives on this
stuff there's no evidence of any
syndrome disease or otherwise of
sensitivity to radio frequencies okay
there however i will say
that you can't prove a negative okay so
all i can tell you is right now there's
no evidence of this occurring how and i
would make the point
that
these people have been exposed to these
exact frequencies
since the advent of television
okay
so
if they were going to experience what
they're experiencing now
given that television is at as high
power if not higher
and the same thing with radio even
before that i mean marconi broadcast at
megawatts
okay
we would be seeing other people long
before
recent history have this my wife's a
behaviorist she does she's a director of
special ed we saw this with autism okay
so autism everybody thinks that autism
came about in 1992 or so it exploded
throughout the country
unfortunately that's not true we just
didn't diagnose it so we had a whole
pile of people that had autism we're
suffering in silence we have you know if
you go back and look at the behavior of
einstein newton um mary curie
they all had autism or at least
apparently did based on their behavior
and and comments that people made they
were never diagnosed it still existed
okay so we discovered that we weren't
treating autism and diagnosing autism
effectively so rates of autism went
through the roof okay but what we also
have discovered is that you can diagnose
autism at five months before any
vaccinations have occurred
and i would draw a direct parallel to
that
because we've we've confused correlation
with causation
okay and it's very important and i'm
very sympathetic to everybody on these
topics
and i would love for medical science to
figure out what's going on with these
people that do have these conditions
because we need to fix it but at the
same point we have to recognize that
correlation is not causation and we're
not controlling the variables so we
can't simply can't know
but all of the controlled data
says you know it's like it's like the
greenhouse effect
we know for a fact the greenhouse effect
exists because if you fill a fish tank
seal it and you fill it with co2
the fish tank will heat up faster than
the
tank that has regular oxygen in it we
know that for a fact okay but then you
put it in the wider systemic ecosystem
and then all of a sudden it becomes not
so clear it becomes much more difficult
to control and understand
right and that's why all the projections
are off so while these because we don't
know all of the things that are going on
all the inputs
but we do know that if you go and put a
hand
in a box that is sealed as a faraday
cage and you expose it to radio waves
below ionizing radiation you will not
see any dna damage no matter how long
you leave it in there at whatever rate
you want to broadcast it at you will not
see any dna damage whatsoever you will
see heat build up they will tell you
that their hands getting uncomfortable
because of the heat if you expose it to
their ears at specific frequencies they
will experience pain
as a result of doing that because
there's a specific frequency that causes
your eardrum to vibrate and cause pain
but what it won't do is it will not
cause dna damage it will not cause your
cells to break down it will not cause
your red blood cells to deform or do any
of these other claims it just doesn't
happen
so
there is absolutely probably something
going on
that we don't understand that is
correlative
to cell phones but not caused by cell
phones
yeah i like to say a few words uh thank
you much for your presentation and i
am
thankful that you that you mentioned the
phrase correlation versus causation
because i think we've used that phrase
here often
uh obviously people are experiencing
difficulties
um
in certain areas that seem to correlate
with certain types of technology but
causation may still be up
up in the air
the bill that we
had before us here
had suggested that
a safe distance of i forget 1760 feet or
something like that
1640 i'm sorry
would
would be an acceptable um
solution to uh
to help with some of these people's
issues
um
i don't know
how what you're feeling uh would be of
that distance
i would like to get your thoughts on
that distance but also
is there
you know there's there's
there's maybe the very best way you can
build something and then maybe there's
something that will still work but maybe
give a little relief to someone else
even though it may or may not be the
cause for it so i guess i'll ask you the
same question is there anything with
this technology and i don't mean just
the new 5g but just anything
going up there
is there anything that could be
redesigned or repositioned in a way that
at least we might
say that we're attempting to mitigate
some of these people's issues that they
have even though we're not quite sure
what's causing
there is that on there we go um so
to answer your the first part of your
question
i understand exactly where the 1760 feet
it's what
500 meters or whatever the actual number
is
rounded it i understand where that
number comes from it's using the inverse
square law that i uh used a little while
ago to come up with what what's the
dissipation in open air of these
frequencies that will get you to a
specific lower level okay
i'll note that millimeter waves don't
even go through glass okay so if you're
using a millimeter wave 5g signal and
you stand in front of that window
and there's one
and there was a light pole on that
street on the street right back here
that had a milliliter millimeter wave
broadcast your signal would be 95 less
just going through the glass
and if you walked
along the wall
it would be gone
and it would automatically fall back to
mid band and low band frequencies okay
so
so it's dubious to me
that
without outright banning millimeter wave
that number is meaningless because
there's no way that you can get 765 feet
away
where millimeter wave is actually going
to be useful
okay so literally if you go and put in
that limitation you're effectively
ending millimeter wave
and i will tell you that you are going
to absolutely harm the least privilege
in our community by doing so because the
most cost effective way to deliver
internet and thus technology which is
the number one indicator for somebody
having access to being able to rise up
the ladder in our society is having
access to information and education
if you go and ban this technology you're
banning the cheapest most affordable and
most accessible form of internet that we
have in the world
okay and even if you were to do so and
i'm gonna stress this because it's vital
is that starlink is literally
broadcasting it over your head right now
so the second you step outside and
you're not under a concrete wall
you're getting it so no amount of bands
in new hampshire is going to stop that
because that's federal you can't stop it
it's been approved by the fcc
okay so
i it would be a token jester at best in
new hampshire to go and ban this because
it's just not going to happen and for
the record jeff bezos's competitor to
starlink uses 18 gigahertz even higher
frequency so if you think that well 12
gigahertz is okay but 18 isn't there's
uh yeah i did have a second part of the
question was
um
is there anything that could be done
with insulation designs that could
at least
pay homage to the fact that
you know a little further away
maybe vertical or horizontal whichever
way it is would any of that make any
difference at all or
be in any way
contributory to perhaps um
finding out if the people have a less of
an issue
so
there's actually technology built in to
5g and lte which is nemo which we we
talked about so you're effectively and
cumulatively getting about 1
10 24th
the power so 1 1000 and 24th the amount
of exposure in any given period of time
as a result of that technology because
that's the cycle frequency of 5g in
amiimo is is it will cycle and reframe
the antenna and rephrase the antenna
1024 times a second
okay and they're the second generation
of 5g which will just be continually
added onto and your phone will likely
have to be replaced um when they go and
add that on the next version quadruples
that to 4096. okay so you're going to
get less and less radiation as 5g
continues to develop because
memo is the number one way that they
increase the amount of bandwidth that
they have in any given frequency range
so it is going to get better over the
lifespan so as an example lte has 23 i
believe different versions of it
okay and every single one of those got
better every single one of those use
less and less power 5g is going to do
exactly the same thing we're on version
7.
there's every reason to believe that
there's going to be at least 20
variations of that before we get to 6g
so every single version of it will get
better okay but
the difference between vertical and
horizontal that you might hear about is
only the antenna okay so if you if you
have an antenna that's shaped vertically
okay it's not going to receive a
horizontal polarity properly because the
slits like this the radio waves like
this it can't fit
but if it's vertical like this and the
radio waves this way it can come in and
it will be amplified through the horn of
the receiver okay so if anybody's got a
radar detector you don't have to admit
it um but if you have a radar detector
this is out you can absolutely prove
this to yourself right now go find a
police officer friendly police officer
that's broadcasting on his radar gun and
just turn your radar detector sideways
the signal will drop in half
because police radar broadcasts
horizontally and if you turn it this way
it will
receive less than half because the
signal will be less uh it will not be
amplified as much through the feed horn
okay so the human body yes is vertical
but we're talking about waves that are
in centimeters and things like this
you know
a millimeter wave is smaller than the
width of an average man
uh in signal strength and width versus
other ones like like
low band is is feet and meters wide
right and even longer so
you're still going to pick it up and
there's not going to be any significant
large difference between it and it's
built the way it is because um
the the way it's designed maximizes the
coverage area at the at a given strength
so if you go and do anything else it's
going to be less efficient which is
going to mean you're going to either
have to increase the strength
or more likely you're going to have to
increase the number of towers to cover
the same number of people
okay
thank you uh representative abrami
thank you miss chair i have a couple of
questions so first um let's talk about
millimeter waves
my understanding is that that experiment
hasn't worked that well
uh that that some of the companies have
are thinking of banning or already
abandoned that strategy
because of like what you're saying it's
it's very low frequency it doesn't go
through walls very well
it's subject to interference trees
whatever it might be
so is is that a true statement that is
that from your perspective has has that
kind of a failed the millimeter wave
concept and they've
by all indications the answer is yes um
to an extent so there are specific uses
there it's being used and i think it's
being used very effectively but if you
actually look at any of the cell phone
companies uh deployment they all have
maps on their website you can go and
look them up that show where their
millimeter coverage is they started mass
deployments in new york city and a few
other heavy urban populations um
and they've all but stopped
okay there is some
new developments that are occurring that
i'm aware of that um are
really complex ways of broadcasting that
may change that
but i don't think that functionally
you're going to see massive widespread
distribution and honestly i don't even
know if there's anywhere in new
hampshire where it would actually make
monetary sense to deploy a millimeter
wave you might in like downtown concord
or um maybe in a shopping mall or let's
say in uh fisher cast stadium right
something like that that's where it
would make sense if you've got 30 000
people for a baseball game
um and it's all open air because
everybody's sitting in a stadium that's
an ideal spot to use millimeter wave
okay because you have so much bandwidth
and it's open air and there's nothing
obstructing you so you can directly fire
the beam right at wherever the cell
phone is and it will just work okay but
in a city street even with mimo bouncing
off walls and things like this
it appears and obviously 18t verizon and
all the rest of them that might
come in here may disagree and they may
say that they're going to start new
deployments but
when you go and look at their maps and
you look at their applications for
deployment you're just not seeing it
like literally vermont goes and puts
every single one of their cell phone
towers is actually publicly available
online you can see the application for
them and they approve them at the state
level
so it actually creates an ideal
environment to you see exactly what's
being deployed
if you go through those filings which i
have
as far as i can find anywhere in any of
their documentation there are literally
zero cell phone towers in the entire
state of vermont even in burlington that
have deployed 5g uh millimeter wave
right thank you for that and as far as i
can tell here in new hampshire there are
zero as well right
so
one thing the 5g commission that i
showed again that
we concluded right early on that 5g is a
marketing concept
and that what we're really talking about
is radiation in general so we we kind of
morphed as a 5g commission to a
radiation commission if you will
so let me use your mur
example
so someone someone's not going to have
build a house run underneath that tower
now are they
um there are
restrictions and most of those are
actually to do with the tower falling
down
as to how far away from the tower the
towers have to be and it's mostly to do
with the risk of it getting hit by
lightning because it's a massive
lightning rod if the power is if the
pole is i don't know how those are
pretty high right those are yeah they
can be a thousand feet higher more but
there are people that live right beside
radio towers but power density i mean
it's all about power density i mean it's
it's it's the it's the watts per meter
squared
i agree with you 100 on that
and so
so if it's if it's broadcasting at
500 whatever you said 500 watts fifty
so how far away would it have to be safe
for someone to even be near it
underneath the antenna
underneath it the signal's so weak that
it's irrelevant because it's going that
way because it creates a cone if you're
underneath it like if you go and stand
right underneath the cell phone tower
just go find one you'll find that you
have very little signal off that tower
but as soon as you step out into the
cone it will get significantly stronger
so i'm not aware of the exact
fcc regulations but i can tell you that
there is very very limited little
limitations on how close to a tower you
can be because as an example before the
world trade center uh happened uh the
top of the world trade center had
literally every single television
channel in new york was broadcasting off
the top of the world trade center
they lost 90 of their cell phone
coverage for their backbone because
virtually all the low band frequency
coverage uh for new york city that would
get you into parking garages and things
like this was broadcasting off the world
trade center and literally there were
people inhabiting the floor immediately
below the tower right
so let's get back to the 500 meter um
thing so
we were looking for
a solution
uh and we we looked at the research out
there and yes there's research in this
research i agree with you on that
but it seemed like the studies that we
saw showed epidemiological studies i
mean that actual actual
cancers and things like that
that once you hit the around 500 meters
that seemed to be where
you know studies shown that the cancer
level off
that that that was the basis of our
of our our conclusion
so
all we're trying to do here today is to
say is there an is there a compromise i
mean how how i mean i asked myself how
far away would i want to sell tower for
my forget about the 5g
the small cell towers let's talk about
the big cell towers which have multiple
antennas on them by the way all
broadcasting at the same time
at very low wattage
that very low wattage
at 100 to 300 watts of power
there isn't a cell phone tower in the
united states that
broadcasts over a kilowatt right and
those are only in the in the midwest
where they cover hundreds of miles right
so
how safe would you feel how you know
i've climbed towers that were active
to answer your questions but living but
living next to one is a different story
i mean you you have a constant
buildup of exposure over time so no
that's not true let's let's be specific
it's exactly like my pot of water
boiling example
you have to have an excess amount of
energy more than whatever the body is
that it can radiate out
before you have any buildup at all
okay
so
literally it's exactly the same thing as
if i boil that water if i can go to a
seven and i get a perfect boil and i go
to eight and it boils over if i stay at
seven
i've not i have no excess radiation and
no buildup because it's literally the
same thing we're just talking about heat
radiation it's a radio wave okay versus
a cell phone tower so until you get past
that tipping point
of radiation there is literally no build
up and in fact your body will radiate
out all of it back to zero
and it won't build up at all but you're
still talking about heat
but
radio waves are the same thing
yeah but but there's but
but there are studies showing that
there's impact on dna
only in ionizing radiation above uv i
don't know i just talked about the
american toxicology program study
every single study of
this was a 30 million study by the
federal government right so i've i've
looked at all of these studies and maybe
this is a new one from the last time
that i spoke before this committee and
literally every single one of them was
either withdrawn or had significant
issues identified with it upon research
when i researched them okay every single
study that made a positive assertion
about correlation
and causation to radio waves and cancer
or any other dna damage okay there are
no
studies by the fda and i understand
after the last few years that some
people may or may not put weight in that
but there are no accepted studies by the
fda that have not been withdrawn that
show that there is any possibility of
dna damage below ultraviolet
well again a year ago we had the
the folks who
were involved in the study that i was
just talking about
testifying to us right at that point
they didn't withdraw anything so i just
want to point that out go on to the
fda's website again if he does if he
doesn't do studies does the fda accepts
the studies and they're there for this
purpose and there are multiple studies
and submissions and working groups
within the fda
on this exact topic so
well there are lots of studies that
suggest that there may be something
there are absolutely none that i am
aware of none that the who even admits
okay because they've studied this
backwards and forwards and have claimed
made these exact same same claims there
are no studies that even the who who is
absolutely obsessed with this admit show
causality
well wh so causes it a uh
they call it as uh uh was that second
level carcinogen
group two b
probable but also the state of
california why would they do that why
would they do that hedging their bets
for exactly the same reason that the
state of california calls virtually
every single thing that is made by human
your best
i i don't want to ascribe motivation
because i don't know their motivation
but if you look in in california because
of prop 65 or whatever it is
basically every single thing that you
buy
shows a label on the bottom saying that
this has been is known by the state of
california to probably cause rape cancer
it's exactly the same
question one last question mr chair all
right me quick please okay
so
is there any distance
that you would think would be reasonable
for setback on a cell tower from
someone's home or property
i would say whatever the
fcc regulations for risk of lightning
strike and towers falling is probably
also a reasonable setback and i'm sure
the fcc actually has a setback for how
close you can actually be i don't know
exactly what the regulation is
based on a given wattage i would say
that those regulations are based in
science based on safe testing that all
of the evidence shows this and even i'll
give you an example there was a claim
about 10 years ago that police officers
were having higher levels of testicular
cancer because they were leaving their
radar guns and their laps turned on
turned out to be fiction they're
literally and and to be clear a radar
gun broadcast
well more than a cell phone tower does
and they were putting it in their laps
and that that same
study was withdrawn because they didn't
control it for all the variables so
literally a police officer putting us a
radar gun blasting away on his lap is
not causing cancer
okay so i would suggest that the fcc's
numbers are absolutely accurate and and
quite honestly very pessimistic why did
why do the firefighters in california
win their case
and there's no there's no towers on top
of the fire stations any longer in
california a legal verdict is not a
scientific verdict
there are countless cases of courts
ruling in favor of plaintiffs based on
an emotional response to horrific events
that had nothing to do with science
okay i'm going to
we we're into our lunch period here i'll
take one last question from
representative lewicki and i but before
that uh
how many other people are here that
wanted to speak today
uh we we will have another interim study
meeting but it won't be until the fall
but i'm just trying to get a judge for
for right now how many people want to
speak
okay so we we can break for lunch and
let's have one last question and then we
can determine what time to expect from
lunch okay thank you mr chairman thank
you for taking my question returning to
the actual bill might not a standard
based upon street level exposure in
watts per square centimeter or any unit
of measurement be more sensible than
something
arbitrary saying 500 meters for
everything because clearly a 2 watt
transmitter at
lamp post level is going to be a whole
lot less of an issue than a cell phone
tower doing hundreds of watts
absolutely so
as i said
the obvious number for that would
literally be the tipping point it's
exactly like the pot of water if the
water boils over you obviously have too
much radiation too much heat being
generated which can damage your skin
exactly like a sunburn where your skin
peels and things like this
so literally that would obviously be an
excellent limit to use as a measurement
scientifically
the good news is is that the fcc
okay um
i guess we'll break for lunch because we
have more speakers for this session and
we can come back here by quarter past
one
and hopefully we'll finish up this
session before too long after that with
our additional speakers
okay it's uh 20 past one so i guess we
can get going on this i understand that
we're going to do this next session in
in the form of a panel so
if i'd like to have everyone's names it
would be great for the record and for
the clerk's enjoyment
you want to start searching
i'll start um i'm gary woods i'm a
representative from merrimack 23
serving beau and dunbarton
i served on the 5g commission back in
the day
a little bit of my background the reason
i'm going to say some of the things i'm
going to say is
i was originally a physicist
and did work with quantum mechanics and
molecular orbital theory
relative to light and
molecular interactions
then did my graduate at berkeley
and that little school on the west coast
and they did my graduate work at hopkins
before i went into medicine
and retired as an orthopedic hand
surgeon
along the way i did serve on national
council for
scientific affairs for the ama
and have stayed involved with a lot of
physics and its relationship to medicine
i'm ken chamberlain i too served on the
new hampshire commission
while i served on the commission i was
professor and chair in the department of
electrical and computer engineering at
the university of new hampshire
right now i'm working i've left the
university i'm working as a founder in a
high tech startup company i think the
message there is i'm very much in favor
of high tech and there's nothing that i
would suggest
that would impair that
moving forward with high tech so
everything that we're going to be
talking about
can be done hand in hand with the
promotion of high tech
i think that's about all i have to say
about
me
thank you dr chamberlain and he did also
serve on the new hampshire commission
that investigated this issue my name is
cecilia doucette from ashland
massachusetts i'm the director of
massachusetts for safe technology as
well as an international non-profit
called wireless education
like many of you i had no idea there was
anything to be concerned about with
biological effects of today's wireless
technology
i ran many campaigns for our local
school district that helped us to bring
technology in
wireless infrastructure ipads
chromebooks smart boards minis
and then one night a friend of mine
who's an electrical engineer tipped me
off that there could be biological
effects
i am a master's level technical and
professional writer
and so i began to do my own
investigation into the science and i was
astounded to find literally thousands of
peer-reviewed studies all over the world
showing that today's wireless technology
is indeed highly bio active and we
helped my public school district in
ashland massachusetts become the first
in the united states to begin taking
precautionary measures
with radio frequency so today's message
is certainly not no technology but now
that we have the science showing it is
extraordinarily biologically active it's
time to bring the pendulum back into the
center and learn how to deploy today's
technology safely
house bill 5
is a really wonderful start to that i
would like to correct something in the
record that was stated earlier today in
that when you get to that 500 meter mark
or 1
640 feet that that's where it it stops
it's not that's where the slope begins
to drop off
we don't catch up till death rates in
the regular population until double that
amount at about a thousand meters so it
is it is already a compromise
to do
a 500 meter setback when the science is
showing us that the death rates the
neurological impacts with sleep anxiety
depression
and other neurotoxicities are happening
well within that range
uh this is a panel so feel free to jump
into
to state your next statement
okay
so something that was stated earlier in
earlier presentations is that science
does not show harm from a radiation
exposure at least not below 9i in
ionizing and non-thermal
that's not what we found on the
commission remember you formed the
commission the legislature formed the
commission to kind of figure out what's
going on because there's been a lot of
contradictory information out there
so the commission was formed to bring
together the right people with the right
expertise to really come up with a
definitive answer about what's going on
with regards to radiation
so people were brought in like
physicians couple of physicians
epidemiology toxicologists physicists
people with a background to understand
what's going on to be able to interpret
the scientific literature and then come
up with a report
that says what's going on and we've done
that
back in
2020 in november we released our report
and that reports pretty clear
that there is harm from
exposure to radiation from low-level
radiation like what you get from a cell
tower and like what you get from your
cell phone we didn't make a distinction
between 5g and 4g because what we found
is that radiation from any of these
sources particularly digital radiation
has roughly the same effect and we can
talk more about that in a moment because
that effect has been documented many
many times but what i wanted to talk
about was how do we know that and this
is something that of course is very
important how did you come to your
conclusions
well we brought in experts is one thing
and so we brought in nine experts with
backgrounds related to cell phone
radiation exposure radiation exposure
period and health
and all of those nine experts except one
told us about the dangers of cell phone
radiation
in in you know in very clear terms the
one
outside expert that we brought in that
said that there's no harm associated
with radiation exposure
was a representative from the cell phone
industry and the only paid person all
the other experts that came in and
talked to us were volunteers and this is
the only paid person and the paid person
the owner who said that there is no harm
associated with exposure
so going back and i'm sorry to be going
on and on about this but it's important
i was listening you know to what people
were saying earlier and i just totally
disagree
because the science is crystal clear why
else would a group like the the new
hampshire commission you that was
convened by the legislature why would we
come up with some statement about harm
when there is no harm
none of us were getting paid and none of
us are affiliated uh i mean all the
signers of the majority report i should
say are not affiliated with the cell
industry so why would we come up saying
that there's harm when there is no harm
and how did we come up to that
conclusion
well the first thing i did uh when i was
appointed to the commission is i started
reading
i went to the peer-reviewed journals
and started reading and by the way one
reason one function i performed on the
commission was to help vet the the
referee journals when you'll hear from
the cell industry that the only issues
or only articles that show harm are
those from fringe journals and they're
cherry picked so one function i
performed was to vet those articles
because i was an associate editor for
ieee transactions
in a prestigious journal so what i did
when i first started finding articles
showing harm i got together with our
college uh librarian you know phd and
library sciences to say hey are these
fringe journals how could we how can we
refi identify a friend's journal what
are they all about
well so what we did is we found the
articles that made these claims very
strong claims about harm associated with
radiation exposure and started looking
at those journals are is this a fringe
journal and the answer
just saying it very quickly is no high
quality journals with people from
recognized universities making claims
about the harm there are no fringe
journals
there are friends journals but we did
not use fringe journals we use high
quality journals in coming to our
assumptions now the other thing
they claim is that we do cherry picking
but let's look at that let's look at the
numbers
back in 2010
fully
28 percent of the articles
about radiation harm 28 percent of them
from the under industry funded studies
showed harm so only 28 of
industry-funded studies showed harm in
2010 now to me that would be a concern
but apparently to industry it wasn't but
in that same year
uh fully 60 it was over 60 of
non-industry funded studies showed harm
so you're seeing a pattern there but now
let's fast forward to 2020
and in that year over 90 percent of
studies performed by anybody showed
oxidative stress as being associated
with exposure to fields
now
oxidative stress that has to do with
free radicals many of you have heard of
them oxidative stress
oxidative stress leads to inflammation
which leads to cancer so there is a
well-known mechanism that is shown in
the majority of papers well over the
majority of scientific papers so this
isn't just something obscure that we're
making up no we have hard science
showing this to be the case
either if you want to take it from there
well
you'll have to
bear with me i'm going to try and
explain a couple of basic physics
principles and terms that will help you
understand some of the
terms that have been used but also the
implications
of some of the processes that are in
place
i again i would like to emphasize that
at no time
have
has there been any discussion of being
anti-technology
uh it's it's
the
careful use of technology uh that we're
after uh and i emphasize again and again
uh having been in physics and medicine
technology is taking off at an
unbelievable rate
our social cultural parameters for which
we deal with that
are coming along at a percolating pace
we're not able to keep up and we see
that across the board another commission
i'm on fire on is the pfas or the
peripheral carbon
um again
teflon everybody loves technology teflon
but it's plefural carbons and look what
we're dealing with uh some of the
artificial turf is
uh pfas uh and that leeches in so we're
but we're struggling with our technology
what do we do with it
uh and that requires us to think about
the science as well
um
i would like to hit on a couple of
points one is the
pot of boiling water
that's a good analogy for what's called
macroscopic
consideration in other words
our size
except we're dealing with
interactions of
radiation at the micro
level
the physics is very different
at the micro level
um
and i the boiling pot uh is
water boils at 212
but that doesn't mean all molecules are
running around at the same rate some you
can see even are
going off
and some are not
the temperature you measure is an
average
some are much hotter and
often they go into space
some are not
so that's what i mean by we're looking
at it by sticking the thermometer in the
boiling pot that's a macroscopic but we
know at the microscopic level things are
very different and that's we have to
keep in mind that that can rule the
world
just like we found like coveted 19 is
how big
and it's rule in the world
right now so the microscopic is really
crucially important for us
to look at the microscopic we have to
use terms like statistical
thermodynamics
and we see that
happen even even with ice you put ice
out on the pavement even though it stays
below 32 degrees you come back in a few
days and the ice is gone
it sublimates because the activity
nothing sits still
even at zero things are moving around
uh and one second please the clerk has a
question i'm trying to clerk and use the
word i didn't catch statistical what
thermodynamics thank you though i heard
it that's okay sorry about that
um
so even though it's below 32 degrees
there are certain molecules that are
moving faster and they pop off into the
atmosphere and eventually they all pop
off because their things are moving
around and they disappear
yes
isn't that evaporation that that well
and it says it's called sublimation when
it's from the solid state
into the gaseous phase
it's from a liquid
to the gaseous phase is evaporation
okay the same idea but yes
that's
um
so what we're saying is that the bonds
that hold molecules together
in ice are broken
and
can
disappear into the atmosphere
sublimation or in the case of water
evaporation
so we have to make sure we focus on the
microscopic
the term ionization is the next term i'd
like to address
and the role of ionization
is crucial for our bodies
okay
but our whole body is ionized
how do your nerves work
by transporting ions
across membranes potassium and sodium
ions are transported across membrane
muscle contraction how do your muscles
work
by controlling ions calcium ions in what
are called the lateral cisterni in a
sarcomere the little unit of your muscle
gets released that causes the
contracture
but that we're controlling ions
we love ions our whole body is on it how
do your bones grow
their bones grow because of what's
called piezoelectricity
the bones bend and that causes a
change in the physical separation or in
a sense local ionization
and that stimulates the cells nearby
that sense that
charge difference
and they put down some calcium
our whole body's ionized
so it's not ions themselves
it's how they're misused
okay
the last complicated term i'd like to
explain which has a significant
difference and i
actually did a lot of work in this area
it's called proton tunneling and don't
i'll explain what that means
water
is made of hydrogen which is basically a
proton
and electrons basically okay
now when dna comes together we know how
dna is put together they're sort of like
fingers and there's hydrogens here
and they come together and they bond by
hydrogen
bonding okay
hydrogen bond on one side of the dna
says i want the proton
the other side of the dna says no i want
the proton
and so this this proton is is caught in
between and there's called a potential
barrier in other words it's on this side
and it's there's a barrier like a wall
and the proton sits on one side of that
wall with one molecule
the other molecule here can't get it
because there's a wall there
but
in quantum mechanics
there's a certain probability
that that proton can sneak through the
wall
and get on the other side well what
happens if that happens
well uh t
then becomes an a when it's red
and a g
becomes a c
when that's red you go have an error
well our bodies can control that to some
degree
notice i said to some degree
but that can occur even at just room
temperature
that proton tunneling
it doesn't take a level of ionizing
radiation
to make that happen
that's at a very low level
and that was discussed
in a paper by a fellow named pair all of
louv dean in 1963
when i was a senior at berkeley
and i thought well that's pretty cool so
i began studying it myself
and he postulated back then because of
this proton tunneling that errors might
occur
and indeed we know that that can be the
case
we know that these hydrogen bonds also
play not just in dna
but in almost every reaction in our body
our body is controlled by little gadgets
proteins called
enzymes
enzymes are collected into a mass
and their structure their
three-dimensional structure
is absolutely crucial
for the activity that they perform if
that shape is changed
we have a problem
enzyme doesn't work
or it works in a way that's detrimental
again those are hydrogen bonds
that do that
there's that proton tunneling sneaking
up again
running through the tunnel
so dna
enzyme control
through the proteins
so that is a major factor and it is at a
level that is
way
down below the ionization level
lastly i would like to introduce you a
term called a superposition principle
some places would call it resonance
in other words
these activities working together
okay and it's very easy to an example
would be
you have your grandchild actually
grandkids because i do it with my
granddaughter all the time she likes to
be out on the swing
so what do you do you get behind the
swing you
push okay
comes back again a little bit of a push
you don't push very hard
but you keep the swing and even just a
little bit of extra goes higher
that means you're in sync
okay you're in resonance
now if you pushed when she was coming
back with the same force
she'd come to a stop
so you're
out
of resonance
and the same thing can happen inside
molecules
this force
that force
that force come together and they're all
little forces but when they come
together
uh oh
big time
you run into some problem potentially
run into some problems
so much for the technical stuff but i
think these are issues
that are crucially important and
understanding not the macroscopic not
the boiling pot of water
but the actual interaction
at the molecular level which we know
happens and i hearken back as early as
1963 parallels ludene published a paper
saying hey guys
this happens
and
i've tried to stay up with it since but
uh sorry for the technical aspect i'll
um represent brummie yeah so so dr
what's you you're saying that
that
that with enough radiation all around us
that the potential of the interaction of
that radiation with these mechanisms is
part of the issue
absolutely they can work together they
don't have to work independently
now they have the whole issue of what's
called super
superposition
and that's and that's the basis of
that's the basis some of some of the
more recent papers that are coming out
on this issue correct thank you
remember
i heard you listen to you
why what is different about 5g as
opposed to television that's causing uh
in your view any difference no we're not
we as as was pointed out by
representative abrami
the term 5g was used as a guidepost but
became very clear that we had to be
aware of all radiation and we did we
we looked at that so the the the issue
of 5g that it that its energy range
is
carries more energy than
longer wavelength the shorter the
wavelength the higher the energy
or frequency the wavelength and
frequency are sort of interchanged
interchangeable
but
so
once you get up into the higher
frequency range they carry more energy
and that's that's really the concern but
we didn't restrict ourselves just to
that
representatives
about
um
four hours ago
i suggested
cumulative effect
so if we have to shave
that effect
and we can't eliminate
i mean you you take people's cell phones
away you talk about revolution
um
i mean that i'm serious and it also is
what then
are we to do
we have to find ways such as having your
cell phone automatically stop radiating
when you're
not reusing it
and that can be done already with
technology on your cell phones you can
have it such you can pick when it's
radiating or not
um but id is like that so you you
minimize it as much as you potentially
can being aware of these other factors
that come into play but get industry on
board to help us
eliminate uh and diminish
both the intensity the frequency and the
proximity
with the radiation again it's smart
usage not non-usage
so may i follow up
on on my particular cable box
i can
after a certain amount of time it'll
shut off
if i'm not watching it
does that save radiation by just
shutting it off
yes i mean the radiation that's going to
occur sure yeah if you shorten the time
yes but if you just shut your phone off
does that
not necessarily because it's still
receiving
uh
yeah it's still interacting there's just
because you're not talking doesn't mean
that it's not interacting
so does that mean again with the
simplistic mind that i have and all my
chemistry and other classes that came
rolling back like a nightmare
do
it's the proximity so what's right close
to us like this particular these things
in here and his computer
are
radiating but when we add something
bigger like
like a higher frequency like a 5g
does that do
more harm especially when we can get
away from it if we are sheltered we we
make the assumption that any that the
intensity and duration and proximity are
the things that increase the level of
harm
now we understand you can't get away
from all radiation okay cosmic rays are
coming through all the time okay
now probably the biggest
particle you're subjected to is
neutrinos
probably on the order of 10 trillion to
15 trillion per second penetrate your
body
right now as you sit there
count up cow thousand one thousand
fifty ten to fifteen trillion neutrinos
went through your body while i said that
so it's
and that comes from primarily the sun
but i i we can't avoid all radiation
we have to live with it
and we want to take advantage of it to
our to to our advantage that's not the
purpose
our purpose is to ask the question
okay
are we doing harm if we find we're not
that's fine okay it's like i used to
tell my daughter they'd come and have
three daughters and
they'd come in and give me an argument
about something i'd say great that
sounds pretty good
what about the other side
roll the eyes and
nothing happens and i said well you do
know
until you can argue both sides
you're prejudiced
now the side you are
arguing may be correct but if you can't
argue the other side what you are
arguing is a prejudiced position
and what we're trying to do here in the
commissioner we did
is to try and look
and be objective and ask ourselves
you know
what where does this fall in the
spectrum of the rise of technology it's
usefulness
versus its detraction
and that's a question we're trying to
address
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
i will ask at the end the same question
i asked the previous speaker however
when we're talking about these things
we're talking about you know in terms of
resonance we're talking about
frequencies and one would think that
perhaps the frequencies are critical and
some may be worse than others
and then the amount of power and it gets
back to
would it not make more sense rather than
saying 500 meters to say
watts per square centimeter or
microwatts per square centimeter
at street level or in residence nearby
and that would give us a
perhaps more difficult standard to
administer but it would give us a
reasonable
thing to work with which would allow us
to
use the prop technology as well as we
can i would i was going to say i'm
getting a tap on my shoulder which i was
going to do anyway um the engineer here
will be much more facile so as i
mentioned i am a radio oh sagan
oh okay
all right clunk sorry about your ears so
i'm a radio frequency engineer and so
come up with answers to questions like
this all the time
um so
um
actually could you kind of rephrase it
uh basically what i'm saying is uh
would we not be better off with a
standard that uh tells us about a
particular you know radiation in terms
of watts or microwatts per square
centimeter and that would let us give a
variable position if we've got a 200
watt transmitter uh at street level that
might be a more serious issue than a two
watt transmitter uh at tree level and so
using that standard are using a flexible
standard that is watts per square
centimeter possibly with a frequency uh
variable involved also right thank you
for that question it's it's a good one
it's one that we discussed in the
committee as we were trying to figure
out what would be the best way to write
the legislation yes that is what matters
and i know from somebody who's made a
lot of these measurements myself that i
can have a tower and i can go a distance
away from that tower and i'll get one
reading and then i'll move a little
distance and i'll get a very different
reading
so what you said earlier about that
being hard to enforce was exactly the
reason we came up with distance
so we looked into the referee journals
again and we found that there are
plots of how signal level drops off for
a typical
facility so if you take a typical cell
tower and you go
1 640 feet away from it you you reach a
level that has been identified by many
as being an acceptable level and the
fact that also shows up that 500 meters
at 1 640 feet shows up in multiple
multiple studies i can think of at least
eight studies that recommend that as
being the criterion for distance away
from a cell tower so it's just
straightforward to implement
and
nobody can question whether or not it's
right because here's something else that
fits into that and that is signal level
can vary depending upon atmospheric
conditions so you might go 500 meters
away on a sunny day and get a very
different reading than you get on an
overcast day
so it just seemed like it was the most
straightforward approach to finding a
reasonable and that's what we're looking
for is something that's reasonable and
protects most people
thank you uh representative lauder
please
not her
thank you
when we had the hearing i have all my
notes from that one of the questions i
asked was have any states banned 5g and
the answer was no
so my question this time is have any
states
implemented setting back
5g
i'm going to try to move this around a
little bit without smashing your ears on
a state level no new hampshire is the
first to take this on there are
communities that are banning 5g easton
connecticut for example there was a
grandmother there who figured out the
radio frequency biological effects she
brought this issue to her town leaders
they investigated and they put a
moratorium on 5g just this month they
reaffirmed that moratorium out to the
end of next year until it can be proven
biologically safe
hawaii also had a ban on 5g on one of
their islands
in brussels and other areas around the
world we are seeing this happen
and if i could offer a suggestion
what the world is starting to move
toward for safe technology is fiber to
and through the premises
so right now
5g is powered with a backbone of fiber
optics that runs down the center of the
road and because it's
very much more inexpensive to just throw
up a small cell antenna off of that to
go the last however many feet into your
home or to the person walking on the
ground
that's where the wireless industry would
prefer to have us going is to put up all
these small cells and when they talk
about those millimeter waves not being
able to go very far
what that translates into is the
industry wants to put a cell tower
every two to twelve houses
inside our neighborhoods there are
people all over the country in the world
today waking up with a cell tower in
their front yard
and that's what we want to try and
prevent with the 500 meter setback that
is supported by the epidemiological and
the in vivo in the in vitro studies as
well
as to where biological harm is happening
and i know there was some confusion
about whether our earlier experts today
were current with their science
and when we heard from dr lapin he said
that their investigation concluded in
in 2018 the u.s national toxicology
program which representative abrami
referenced
they concluded a multi-year study it had
been going on for 20 years 30 million
dollars
the national toxicology program is the
world's gold standard on toxics research
they went in 20 years ago expecting to
prove that cell phones and towers and so
forth are safe
they held an unprecedented three-day
peer review at the national institutes
of health
where world leading experts whose life's
work is investigating the biological
effects of radio frequency
they weighed in and for three days they
talked about this report at the end of
the day and you can all get this right
online just go to the national
toxicology program
cell phone radio frequency radiation
studies
at the end of the day
they concluded clear evidence of tumors
in the hearts and these were done on
rodents in the hearts of male rats these
were malignant schwannomas the schwann
cells are in the lining of the heart
evidence of tumors in the brains of the
rats and additional evidence of tumors
in the adrenal glands of male rats and
when we use that term clear evidence
that's the highest categorization they
can give so we now have conclusive
causation
not just correlation
and as the industry is prone to do
they'll say oh that's just one study
well right on the heels of our
government again the world's gold
standard on toxic investigation after
they concluded clear evidence of dna
damage and cancers the ramazzini
institute in italy completed another
large study on cell phone base stations
or cell towers that corroborated
everything that we found on the cell
phone study so we do not need more
science science is always evolving we
can always improve on it but today
we have enough information to know
better
this document is the bio initiative
report and it compiles peer-reviewed
published scientific literature from
around the world the actual
public document is about 1600 pages that
has summaries of all these scientists
scientific investigations but i will
just read to you from the table of
contents and this is what the science
today
shows us
evidence for damage to sperm and
reproduction and when i started reading
the reproduction studies that's the day
that i found my voice on this issue they
have taken male human sperm
exposed it to a laptop with the antennas
radiating it changed the dna which we
know as a road map to grow a proper
anything
it slowed the motility
and it caused far fewer sperm to be
viable or apoptosis which is programmed
cell death in four hours of radiation
exposure so that's how serious this is
evidence that children are more
vulnerable
one of our previous presenters mentioned
dr gandhi's work well dr gandhi has also
done studies that show that children are
not just little adults biologically
their dna is still forming and we are
damaging the dna
their skulls are thinner their brains
have a higher water content
and we are allowing radiation to our
children as their central nervous system
is developing as their immune system is
developing and the science shows this is
a neurotoxin and a genotoxin
evidence for fetal and neonatal effects
the fetus is the most sensitive stage of
human development
i know a doctor who wore her lab coat
during her hospital rounds through both
of her pregnancies
both of her children now she carried
that phone right on top of the babies
both of her children are now
electromagnetically
sensitive evidence for effects on autism
dr martha herbert who founded the autism
lab at mass general hospital
has come out publicly speaking about
what she sees in the children in her
care and what we know scientifically
about exposure to radio frequency
man-made radiation
and it goes on and on the blood-brain
barrier we have membranes throughout our
bodies that protect sensitive areas from
toxins entering
the science shows from dr powell patcher
and others that this radio frequency
bombardment
as dr chamberlain would say
jackhammering our systems night and day
is causing the blood brain barrier to
open it's opening the membranes that are
supposed to protect our brain
and now we have toxins going through the
bloodstream that can now take a turn
into the brain and so now we have a
whole host of neurological diseases that
we didn't have
20 30 years ago
before the pandemic we were at epidemic
levels of anxiety and depression we're
having suicidal ideation among children
like we have never seen and we are
leaving this radiation pulsating 24 7
unless we know better because when we
know better we do better and that's why
we're here today we've already talked
about cancers and so forth but there was
a new paper that came out just this
spring
on earlier and earlier onset alzheimer's
it used to take 25 years to show up
now we're seeing alzheimer's and 20 year
olds 30 year olds
and it's a neurotoxin
so
dr martin paul is one of our world's
leading scientists on this and for a
long time the industry would say well
there's no mechanism of harm identified
well you've already heard about a couple
of them here today with the oxidative
stress with the rouleaux effect when you
start changing the way
that the blood moves through the
bloodstream
red blood cells free floating
you put
electromagnetic fields on those they
start glomming together and forming a
chain called the rouleaux effect where
your blood can't get to where it needs
to go to oxygenate all your systems
chronic fatigue headaches nosebleeds
nausea dizziness anxiety
we know scientifically
why and how this is happening
so that's all the good news we know and
now we can fix it right
rep cali pits to your question
this is what you do with your cell phone
you plug it in with an ethernet cable to
the back of your router
you buy a little adapter for 20 or 30
dollars and you plug your phone into it
anything that you do on the internet you
can safely do
through a cable you just go into your
device and you turn off all of the
antennas the wi-fi the bluetooth the
locator the hotspot the cellular the
data and if anybody has already upgraded
to a 5g phone
those have separate antennas included
so just with our regular phones we had
six
each one individually pulsing microwave
radiation to make or maintain a
handshake with the nearest cell tower or
router we don't need that
we need to be taught to use the
equipment in the safest way possible or
as the centers for disease control would
tell us
we want to get to alara as low as
reasonably achievable that's already in
place with the cdc for ionizing
radiation
now that we have this it's time we get
policies and procedures in place to get
to as low as reasonably achievable
and for example
if you know you had your cell phone and
rhett partial had his
tablet or laptop there
and you need to plug in more than one
all you need to do is buy a little
fifteen twenty dollar device called an
ethernet switch
then you can plug in as many devices as
you want and the kicker is you are going
to get such a faster speed your
reliability hands down will beat
anything wireless is ever going to
provide your data your security your
privacy is all so much better through an
ethernet cable so that's what we can do
for our own devices and then you turn it
off and you have perfectly safe
technology
at the infrastructure level in our
communities the solution is fiber to the
premises we should not allow the
wireless industry to promote their
agenda to put a cell tower anywhere near
where we live work learn or play
we should be bringing the fiber optics
right to the premises which we already
paid for time and again on our bills for
our cell phones but the industry did
some fancy shell game with the fight the
financing they took the hardwired
broadband money and they started putting
in their bucket for wireless so we have
excellent resources to teach our
communities how to do this
efficiently effectively and safely and
this reinventing wires the future of
landlines and networks is out of a
policy group in washington d.c
dr timothy sheckley was one of the
invited guests to the commission
and this tells us what we need to do so
we're not flying blind here we know the
solutions and at the national level with
the broadband funding that's coming
just this last month they said we are
giving preference to fiber to the
premises so the wheels are starting to
come off the bus for the wireless
industry and they know that
but we need to start protecting now
because it takes time for the science to
catch up to the federal public policy
which is why our country needs the state
of new hampshire to do the right thing
here
with the time we have left i'll
entertain a couple more questions and
then i'll ask if anybody would like to
say anything else that may still be
sitting down here before we uh adjourn
so i'll go to representative kelly pitts
next
i understand what you said about the
i've heard it before but one of the
things this
i believe society is
addicted to and i'll say addicted is the
mobility we want everything here and we
don't want to be
into a plug
so
that is one of the problems
you know i find it myself when i
plug in my phone i can't reach it
i get really upset so i i
i it's not a neat it's not going to be
an easy solution
so you could do that while you're in
your house maybe if you had a long
enough cord like the phone call it used
to stretch 30 feet if you really tried
um
but what do you do about
places like this where you're
you know you're surrounded well when
we're in a meeting we're not going to
get brain tumors unless that's an
explanation for what's wrong
but
you know again that's society yeah it's
education it just comes down to
education once we are able to tell the
public
what the biological risks are and what
the better solutions are it's going to
be like drugs and alcohol and gambling
and pornography adults will make their
choices but it is our responsibility
to protect our children above all else
and if you want a little encouragement
the legal handbook for the massachusetts
boards of health when you asked about
what's going on at the municipal level
they've added four pages into theirs
about cell towers
so this is coming mainstream the
industry would prefer it not but when
rep abrami talked about that lawsuit
against the fcc
there was eleven thousand pages of
scientific evidence medical evidence and
over six thousand members of the public
who have been harmed or their loved ones
have been harmed
all in the public record on docket 1384
with the fcc
at the end of the day the fcc closed
that docket and said we don't need to
change anything
once that hit the federal register the
lawsuits began
and when the lawsuits began and the
judges at the federal level the d.c
circuit court ninth district court of
appeals they were presented with 27
volumes of 11 000 pages of evidence and
they looked at the fcc and said
we're seeing this
please share with us what homework did
you do to prove
that your fcc public radiation limits
that are set way high
what is your due diligence and they had
none they said oh the fda said it was
fine
well it was the fda who 20 years ago
commissioned this national toxicology
program that found clear evidence of
cancerous
one might ask why
the fda would turn around to the fcc and
say keep doing business as usual
well when you look at the gentleman who
did that that was dr jeffrey shurin at
the fda and when you investigate a
little bit into his background you will
see that he is married to a woman who is
a partner in a law firm that represents
the wireless industry dr sharon has a
clear conflict of interest and when some
of our earlier testifiers
rattled off or gave to you in his packet
a list of organizations
that support the fcc we need to do our
due diligence on those and you don't
have to dig very far to find heavy
conflicts of interest with the wireless
industry
so we can't take things at face value we
have to do the homework
thank you uh represent plenty you still
have a question
i heard everything you said
and you you you're
pointing this all at 5g
okay
should we shut down television
no what happened with five with
television as dr chamberlain was saying
when we started television it was a
rolling continuous sine wave that was an
analog signal when we got into digital
technology we added a square wave to
that and that's that spiked wave that's
going pulse pulse pulse
megahertz at a million times per second
gigahertz at a billion times a second
and we are not evolved to have that kind
of battering on our cells so it's
everything that's radio frequency
radiation and when the world health
organization
classified this as a group 2b possible
human carcinogen in 2011
they were very clear to state this is
all man-made radio frequency it doesn't
matter what generation it is we need
safety
representative partial question
thank you chair thomas bob thank you for
addressing uh these issues particularly
uh i'd like to hear a lot more about the
fcc and their involvement uh i am
concerned about uh the
level playing field that uh we're
getting and i'm not sure if that's
actually occurring one thing i didn't
hear today is too much is very much talk
about security concerns
i know that if i have a um
landline coming in my home that's fairly
secure
but 5g technology i've heard that it's
entity to come in
take the information they want
through a little bit of software close
it back up and you never know they're
well we as a commission didn't address
that particularly we knew that it is and
they know that it is an issue uh i know
a little bit about that but i don't feel
maybe like going into we should address
that here but yes you are very insecure
with wireless with wired your orders of
i want to thank the panel for
giving us their presentation today i'm
going to ask is there anyone sitting out
there now that would like to come up and
speak
in the next few i intend to end this by
2 30 so
uh
oh mr hancock would you like to come up
and say a few words
so in listening to the
testimony and this goes to what i was
talking about first of all that cable
right there
we were talking about the network cable
that's how an antenna is made so
there is extensive data and there was
advisory put out by the fda and cdc back
in 2011 advising people to
uh minimize the use of use of tethered
ear
buds
with cell phones because it acted as a
antenna
and so as a result it actually magnified
the amount of radiation caused by the
cell phone and cell phone towers and
drove it directly into your head through
one of the openings in your head that
allows radiation to go in through your
ears and it was actually the wire that
actually caused that so as soon as you
plug a network cable
into your cell phone what you're
actually doing is creating a massively
long antenna of however long and what
you're actually doing is because it's so
long it will pick up low frequency
radiation significantly better so when
you're talking low frequency radiation
that could be wider than this room when
you have a 30 foot network cable you're
actually creating an excellent antenna
to go and receive those frequencies so
using a wire that's not fiber optic
to go and try and ameliorate the
radiation you're causing is actually
disingenuous and we know for a fact that
the wire from your ear pad uh earpods
that uh apple saw fit to delete the port
uh so you can't do it anymore we know
for a fact that that was actually
causing more radiation and actually
exceeding fcc regulations on the
limitation of
radiation okay
so we know for a fact that that actually
is a really not good idea as for fiber
you asked the question about security uh
5g uses the same encryption as your web
browser does
every single website that you go to now
is encrypted uh using it in fact um
there was a study done by the pci
commission that
does the uh security and protection for
all uh online payments all all payment
terminals etcetera and they found that
there's absolutely no benefit between a
completely insecure wi-fi
uh access point with these terminals
using the encryption that these
terminals already use which your web
browser uses to go and view the websites
versus an encrypted wi-fi access point
because even if the data can be captured
it doesn't matter because the data is
already encrypted so literally
everything you're doing is already
encrypted
the way that uh you're most at risk
from anything to do with your cell phone
is that your wireless carrier is
actually uh intercepting every single
request you make um for websites you go
to so they can track every single
website you go to and they go and sell
that information in fact they've been
fined multiple times for doing so so
be more worried about the fact that
they're monitoring what you're surfing
not what you're actually entering while
you're surfing okay um because that's
where they're getting you you're you are
literally the product that they're
selling and they make a significant
portion of their
uh revenue that way but to talk
specifically about oxidative stress i
brought up the most recent article there
are three on the nh nih gov website uh
the most recent one that i could find is
pathos physiology of cell phone
radiation oxidative stress and
carcinogenesis with focus on male
reproductive system
it gives you an abstract and some
definitions of their theoretical process
for which radiation might affect the
reproductive sperm counts and damage and
dna within sperm
i'm going to scroll down to the abstract
on my cell phone ironically um
and uh what we'll see when i get down to
there i just got to find the right rate
so it says therefore the sar
limit maximum acceptable exposure limit
should be lowered in cell phones however
more studies are necessary providing
definitive evidence against cell phone
radiation which can be provided in any
virtual studies combined with
computational bile monoling
and then it says it says uh stimulation
of plasma membrane n-d-a-a-d-h
oxidase might you don't need to know any
of the rest of the stuff might play a
central role in the above-mentioned
effects i read this entire thing while
the testimony was just occurring
literally the word might is the most
prevalent word in the entire document
there is absolutely no conclusive actual
evidence in the document whatsoever that
shows that this process actually does
what they think it might do
okay and there is absolutely no claim
whatsoever that there's any causal
effect between this
and cancer
as a result of radiation
so again
we stereo faced with the fact that there
may be people that are sensitive to this
type of radiation there may be some
evidence of this of which we have no
evidence of causality and i can go
through and i have i can forward to
whoever uh evidence of the other uh
assertion of
uh that was made as well that also
starts with an assumption that it that
they're correct
and then says based on that our
conclusion is that this might be
happening except they assume
that cancer is being caused by this
radiation of which there is no evidence
epidemiologically or otherwise in any
statistical form that has any
probability of
that is actually happening so they've
made an assumption that's false to go
and prove their claim from the beginning
so
and
i think it's very very very important to
hear what was said
by the members
that were just up here
what they were effectively saying
is this is the problem the cell phone
not the tower
this being in your pocket is a problem
this exposed to
bare
uh semen is a problem which by the way
your cells are actually specialized and
your skin cells are specialized to
protect you against radiation of which
none of this radiation
uh permeates your skin beyond a
millimeter so
there's no way that any of these body
parts are going to be exposed in the way
that they're suggesting they would be
exposed to
so
the issue is fundamentally first of all
they want this controlled
not the towers
because there's no way that you can turn
off the towers
and yes we can all do our part to turn
off cell phones and things like this
when we're not using them however every
one of these devices goes into power
saving mode and it just sends a
heartbeat periodically and by
periodically i mean many many many
seconds if not minutes between
communications to the tower to say it's
still there when it goes into power
saving mode
so at night time this phone's generating
almost no radiation whatsoever because
it's in power saving mode okay it's
drastically reduced and even the cell
phone towers and memo is the thing that
allows this to happen if there are very
few cell phones on a tower as often
happens at night when they're not active
the tower goes into what's called skip
mode
so it will actually start skipping
broadcasts to be able to save power
because it's in their interest to save
power so as a result they actually skip
and they skip all
a ton of broadcasts that they would
otherwise do so these towers are already
doing this our cell phones are already
doing this
and again
every single study that's on the cdc's
website uses words might may could
this process might work this process may
be what's causing it this problem
process may or may not be causing
something this might be occurring
might what meanwhile starling is
broadcasting down in your head and
nobody in this room is going to be able
to stop it
okay i
we are running out of time time here i
want to ask the question uh to the
general audience uh
is there
are there any other
speakers or vendors or anyone that might
like to come back or come here for an
another meeting
um
i see
sure
i just wanted to
change your name please my name is galen
beach and i'm a licensed certified foot
reflexologist in the state of new
hampshire been practicing for
about 15 years and that's the science of
nerve reflex response in the body
and
one of the comments that i just wanted
to
make
about um security
and such like is we're dealing with our
personal individual telephones
but what the proliferation of
cell towers and telephones and the
increases of power and energy and
frequencies
leads to is the capability for
cyber security
incursions on a large scale so i'm
thinking more of things that have
already happened
since
no different technology has been
introduced i'm thinking for example of
the water treatment facility that was
hacked
and
you know the levels of some
substance were added to
that would ostensibly make this water
poisonous this was done remotely
um anonymously
it was documented in a number of news
programs and
reports so it's not false
um these types of things attacks on
infrastructure
and
you know the
the embassy attacks supposedly
you know attacks may not have been it
might have just been stupidities just so
many people observing this and i've seen
people with like two or three
cell phones on them and they're all
iphones and those are all
you know pumping out in this room right
now like my heart rate is soaring i've
got a terrible headache i always feel
bad in here i'm just wondering does
everybody feel really good
um
since they've had their cell phones on
so
the primary
concern is
that for
at least 20 to 30 years
the frequencies that
and technology devices
that are required and used in
five
5g
technology are considered and called
weapons grade
this is a concern
their weapons grade because of the
capacity
what is the weapon
sound basically in the capacity for
remote
operation of
devices
is
the weapon and do we really want
the capacity the capability of you know
more cell towers with more power being
remo controlled by god knows who and
will require
you know all new devices
more
manufacturing you know so
environmentally with climate change
bad idea
security wise with
you know cyber security bad idea
with the body the the effects on the
human body
totally bad idea
when you know reflexology is a science
of nerve reflex response everything is
being electro
chemically neurotransmitted
by electric
and magnetic forces in your body so
you cannot saturate the body with more
they talk about hitting the skin
if these things are going through walls
they're certainly going deeper than your
skin in reflexology we learn that
the
body
doesn't sense temperature except on the
outside so there's nerve endings on the
outside of the body that can detect heat
but when heat is going on within the
body with the heat buildup
the body is not sensing that
one of the problems one of the causes
for male infertility
is
that because of the eyeballs and the
testes
the
body cannot
circulate heat
out of them fast enough
and this is why the the sperm is
basically cooking
is why your eyeballs are basically
burning all the time
there's very poor circulation
in the eye structure and in the testes
structure
so
heat is retained in those tissues
and
you know unless you can
run the heat off
it's sitting there
cooking your sperm basically
and so
one of the other things is not just
cancer
it's um also infertility it's kidney
disease
it's diabetes
all of these things anyway so
um
sorry that was incoherent but i get very
discombobulated
in um
electromagnetic frequencies that
are a little higher than they used to
and are nervous so anyways uh any
questions
good one
please spell your first name and last
name
g-a-l-e-n
b-e-a-c-h
thank you thank you very much
oh uh
one quick question from representative
where where do you practice here in new
hampshire yes
yep
thank you thank you okay thank you very
much um i'm going to conclude this
meeting now with one question to our sub
committee members who i think
my basic question is this do
[Music]
i i know i said that the next meeting
would be in the fall but uh some people
came to me during lunch and said if we
could have one sooner the only time that
i would have to have one sooner would be
next week uh next tuesday um and so i'm
going to ask the subcommittee if if they
have an appetite for coming here next
week for
one meeting we might uh we might even
discuss what we've heard and we might
even decide on something at the at that
meeting or there might be more people
that want to come to
speak i'm not sure uh i understand there
might be some more people that would
like to speak i'm not sure but i think
the senator would like to speak and
the senator would like to speak we could
would you will you accept zoom testimony
no
no they they can set a team up for us
what day would that be june
june 7th and i have a dinner
plan
consistently sent out on the 7th i don't
know why people have the eighth in their
mind
okay well we could i i could ask to have
it on the eighth which would be a
wednesday if the subcommittee would like
to meet then if not i'm not available
the rest of the month after that so it's
either then or it would be sometime in
september
any
representative partial can i make a
suggestion if i may be the chair and of
uh rep blood that's right here um we are
you are planning a lunch
for a retiring uh
lobbyist could we mix a little business
with pleasure and attend both do you
believe it's down in manchester with the
110 grill that's closer to me than where
i'm living here i'd be glad to meet in
the morning and adjourn
oh you mean to like to meet here and
then go down to lunch
oh
yeah we could do that um certainly we
could we could start here at nine
all right and then um adjourned by
11 or so
11 15.
what's the what's it's up to the
subcommittee
all those
is there there's a
uh straw vote show of hands of those
that would like to meet next tuesday
mr chair
no preference mr chair
i prefer us
not to be up against a hard
stop time if it's only going to be an
hour and a half for me
we may take us
if we especially if we're going to make
a decision that that day
is the plan to make a decision that day
we could decide that day if we are if
we're in a position to make it this way
there could possibly be another meeting
in
december
i mean in september i could i i'm i i
can wait until september as well if if
you want to wait
some some don't want to wait
i mean did you want to wait did you want
to have a meeting for just a couple of
hours and then
come back in september that seems like a
that's the ninth no we're all i'm just
saying okay if it's
thursday we're going lost island
yeah it's a terrible week yeah i mean
it's fun it is it is a bad week and i'm
i'm leaving on the 11th so yeah
i'm all i'm saying is if
if we only do an hour it may not be
we're going to be rushed at the end
that's what i'm getting at it can i
rather not i run out of habits
where we're rushed at the end
i would i would suggest monday however
that doesn't give us enough time to put
it into the calendar it doesn't give us
a legal number of days
to advertise
you have enough time to get it in the
calendar yeah can i say there's a
calendar you have to have i think four
[Music]
we all have had privy
to the commission's report
so
i guess
what i'm going to say is probably
not nice
but i'm i think we need not speeches
we need
information that we've already heard and
we've heard it before
and
if these
people want to come back i think it
would be for questions
and
speeches i think
are what took up a lot of our time and
we didn't need speeches we need
questions
and
that i mean i'm i've never held back on
how i feel so that's how i feel that
a lot of this time was
not wasted because it's all valuable
information but the commission
is we have heard
we all have privy to that report
so
in my mind see you in september is a
wonderful song
and
i think we all have time to do our own
research more research and come back
with something definitive because i have
not heard one
definitive piece of information
if you have a report that says might
or may
that doesn't mean they've said no and
that doesn't mean they've said yes that
means it's a nice way of saying i don't
know
so i think that we really need to chew
this over
some more and
again i haven't heard one piece of
concrete
information and i haven't read one piece
of concrete information and before we do
anything that would impede an industry
or a person an individual
so
and i have to agree that
for some of us it we may have heard some
information that was new although it was
in the report
but also uh
i did i didn't really hear i didn't hear
from the vendors
and i didn't hear
what they might be willing to do or what
they might willing to be
to be acceptable to them
in deference to people that are having
some issues
i heard
black and white you know
yes we do and no we don't
i haven't heard any
real solutions
i don't even know at this point if there
is a legislative solution which is what
the purpose of this meeting is there
might be other private solutions out
there
to help mitigate what's happening but
from a legislative point of view i
didn't i didn't capture anything today
that could be turned into a potential
bill
so i think representative kelly pitts is
right we probably do need to think about
this
and
unless there's strong objection
i guess i can say that we'll
see you in september
and it's at a date and time to be
noticed personally
if it's going to be rushed next week i'd
rather see you in september
okay well i thank you for your time
everybody and if you have any additional
comments please send them in care of the
subcommittee
and
if it's new if there's new information
or if you have some solutions or in
people who have vendors as clients
if vendors would like to reach out to us
and talk to us about what
could or could not be done or
voluntarily or otherwise
something that shows that
that they are listening to people that
have some issues and to find out
if there is anything that could have be
done and maybe there's not
but you know
let's look let's hear we have a couple
of months to put it together
thank you much for coming have a nice
summer
adjourn uh do i have a motion to adjourn
second
you